Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Das ist ganz ausführlich und vier Minuten lang gezählt. Und das ist der Auftakt zu einer Sendung, die Chaos Radio heißt. Was bedeutet, dass der Chaos Computer Club hier in die Fritz-Studios kommt, den Sender komplett übernimmt für zwei Stunden und versucht euch ein Thema nahe zu bringen, genauer zu erklären, mit euch darüber zu reden, was für Effekte das haben könnte, ob man was dagegen oder dafür machen muss und überhaupt. Heute ist das in Gestalt vom Chaos Computer Club die Sill. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und hat mitgebracht zwei Leute vom Gen-Ethischen Netzwerk. Das ist einmal die Uta Wagenmann.
Ja, hallo.
Und einmal die Susanne Schultz.
Ja, auch hallo.
Und es geht heute, wie so oft ja eigentlich, im Chaos Radio und generell bei den ganzen Netz- und Netzpolitik-Diskussionen um Datenschutz, aber heute nicht um diese Digitaldaten, zumindest nicht im Vorgang, sondern um Daten, die in euch alle drin sind, nämlich euer DNA-Profil. Ihr kennt es vielleicht aus Tatort, CSI, was auch immer, Verbrechensaufklärung, die geheimnisvollen Techniker gehen zum Tatort, nehmen mit einem Watte-Stäbchen ein kleines Tröpfchen einer seltsamen Flüssigkeit auf und wissen dann sofort, wer der Täter ist, welche Augenfarbe er hat, welche Gummistiefel er hat und wie viele Zahnlücken er hat. Das alles macht die wundersame Technik des DNA-Profilings möglich, also zumindest im Film. In Echt ist es natürlich ein bisschen anders. Und in Echt gibt es tatsächlich noch ein anderes Problem, dass die Leute vom genetischen Netzwerk damit haben, nämlich da werden Daten gesammelt und morgen soll es einen Aktionstag geben gegen die Datenbanken, die dazu eingerichtet werden. Unter anderem soll dort, habe ich mir sagen lassen, eine symbolische Datenbank in einem großen Eimer voller Spucke versenkt werden. Und warum man sowas macht und was das Problem ist, wie man da hinkommt, dass es dann auf jeden Fall so einen Aktionstag geben soll. Das wollen wir heute hier klären. DNA-Profiling ist das Thema. Wir werden anfangen damit, wie macht man das eigentlich? Wo wird das gespeichert? Aus welchen Gründen? Wo geht das alles hin? Was sind die Probleme damit? Zum Schluss können Uta und Susanne erklären, warum es diesen Aktionszug gibt und was da morgen so passiert. Was überhaupt das ganze Problem damit ist. Ihr könnt währenddessen mitmachen. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Telefonnummer, unter der ihr anrufen könnt. Wir werden erst mal einen kleinen Einstieg ins Thema machen. Und ihr könnt dann sozusagen ab halb anrufen. Zwei Fragen, die heute an die Hörer rausgehen, ist, habt ihr euer Genom schon mal sequenzieren lassen oder irgendwie überprüfen lassen? Und seid ihr möglicherweise schon mal gezwungen worden, im Rahmen so eines Massengentests von der Polizei, das abzugeben, wie das war? Das würde mich tatsächlich mal interessieren. Oder ihr könnt auch im IRC mitchatten, unter freenote.net im Channel Chaos Radio. Und wenn ihr ganz dringend ein Kommentar loswerden wollt, auf fritz.de gibt es natürlich auch eine Kommentarfunktion. Jetzt geht es los mit dem DNA-Profiling. Und als erstes würde ich von euch gerne wissen, wie das funktioniert. Ich kenne es selber nur aus dem Film. Da kommen Leute mit irgendwelchen Stippchen. Die nehmen irgendjemand irgendwas ab. Oder manchmal reicht auch das Haar, das man auf dem Sofa des Verdächtigen gefunden hat, um so ein DNA-Profil zu machen. Wie genau wird denn heute in der echten Welt von den Leuten, die sich dafür interessieren, so ein DNA-Ding aufgenommen? Was brauchen die dafür? Was braucht man mindestens, um so ein DNA-Profiling machen zu können?
Ja, also da braucht man eigentlich gar nicht viel für. Also es reicht eigentlich ein bisschen Hautabrieb. Es reicht ein Haar. Es reicht natürlich auch Blut oder Sperma oder andere Körperflüssigkeiten. Das ist eigentlich ganz bewusst, weil wir die DNA ja in jeder Zelle unseres Körpers haben. Also die ist ja da auf zwei Chromosomen, Quatsch auch 23 natürlich insgesamt, aufgewickelt. Und es ist relativ einfach, aus Körperspuren aller Art, eben DNA zu isolieren.
Also sagen, das Bluttropfen, das Sprichwort hier reicht also. Hautabrieb hört sich jetzt wirklich an, das ist so minimal. Es reicht ein Fingerabdruck, oder was?
Na ja, Hautabrieb ist sicherlich noch am schwierigsten zu gewinnen. Also wenn ich jetzt an einem Glas meine Finger hatte, dann ist es natürlich wahrscheinlich schwierig, wenn ich jetzt nicht so fettige Finger hatte, dann ist das nicht so eine fette Spur, aber das ist alles möglich. Man kann sogar mit Hautabrieb irgendwie...
Das ist auch die häufigste Form, inzwischen, die überhaupt erhoben wird.
Also bei Spuren, wenn man irgendwie am Tatort ist, eines schweren oder eben auch schweren Verbrechens, aber eben oft leider auch eines leichten Deliktes, wie Liebstahl oder so, dann kann man das, wenn es nichts anderes gibt, auch Hautabrieb nehmen.
Das erklärt, warum Verbrecher nicht nur Schutzhandschuhe, sondern auch Schuppenschampo benutzen. Das heißt, ich brauche sagen, irgendwas von einem Körper, das liegt ja dann am Tatort möglicherweise rum, oder ich entnehme das. Es gibt ja diese Massengentests, von denen man immer hört, wo Leute das aufgucken, hier, guck mal her Leute, DNA, wie wird das gemacht?
Na ja, eigentlich wird es bei den Massengentests einfach von der Mundschleimhaut abgenommen. Also gibt es ja diese berühmten langen Weiterstäbchen, nicht unsere kleinen Q-Tips, die wir immer benutzen, wenn wir uns in den Ohren rumpobeln, sondern eben diese langen Bestiebe.
Das wird jetzt vielleicht zu weit.
Das finde ich auch sicher. Aber wir sagen in die Ohren nicht im Mund.
Das sind halt extra Dinger, die stecken in so Röhrchen und werden eben kurz aus dem Röhrchen rausgenommen. Dann wird kurz im Mund rumgefuchtelt, an der Mundschleimhaut eben ein bisschen Mundschleimhaut, also Schleim im Grunde abgenommen, Spucke eben. Und dann geht das Ganze seinen Gang. Also dann ist die Probe genommen und dann geht es weiter ins Labor. Und da wird dann erstmal mit, ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie das funktioniert, ich glaube mit so einer, mit speziellen Substanzen jedenfalls, die werden in die Proben gespritzt und dann werden dabei die Zellkerne zerstört und dann wird die DNA freigesetzt. Weil diese ist ja auf Chromosomen aufgerollt, also so stellt man sich das vor, oder so ist es wohl auch. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall.
Bevor wir es in den Raum fangen lassen, weiß einer von euch, was genau da passiert, wenn ich diese Probe genommen habe, was die dann im Labor damit machen?
Was sie tun müssen, ist auf jeden Fall, die DNA aus den Zellen extrahieren. Also die Zellwand durchbrechen. Zelllyse nennt man das. Damit die DNA dann aus dem Zellkern freigesetzt wird, und man die weiter analysieren kann.
Also man macht die Zelle kaputt quasi, holt das DNA, das Genom da raus und liest das dann wie auf? Also wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Riesige Apparate, die irgendwo drauf?
Also es ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Das wird erst noch vermehrt. Also über diese sogenannte polymerase Kettenreaktion. Das ist so eine Technik, die überall eingesetzt wird, um die DNA zu vermehren. Und dann wird es eben mit einer, also wird es unter Spannung gesetzt, die DNA, und aufgespalten. Und dann kann man eben diese STR-Fragmente, also das ist, ja da muss ich noch vorher noch was anderes erklären.
Da fragen wir gleich mal, okay, ne, warte, sag mal, wir merken es erst mal.
Wir merken uns mal STR. STR ist ein wichtiges Stichwort. Das ist eine Abkürzung, die werde ich gleich noch erklären. Das verspreche ich hiermit. Genau, aber diese einzelnen STR-Fragmente, die man braucht für die DNA-Profilanalyse, die werden dann eben unter Spannung gesetzt. Und die wandern dann durch ganz hauchfeine Gel, mit Gel gefüllte Kapillaren. Und durch die Spannung, also die wandern halt von einem Pult zum anderen, wandern die unterschiedlich schnell, je nachdem, wie lang die sind. Die sind nämlich unterschiedlich lang. Das ist auch ein wesentlicher Punkt.
Das sind dann diese Dinge, die man kennt, also dieses A, A, G, C, T?
Nein, nein, du siehst, was das ergibt, ist eigentlich erst mal ein Leuchtmuster. Die haben halt eine unterschiedliche Geschwindigkeit. Und danach siehst du dann eben, wie lang die sind. Die Durchlaufzeit durch dieses Gel, die ist eigentlich die Bestimmung dafür, wie lang quasi das Fragment ist. Und das ist sehr wichtig, weil die Fragmente unterschiedlich lang sind. Jetzt komme ich zur Erklärung, weil wichtiger ist ja vielleicht auch, das System zu erklären. Was ist eigentlich DNA-Profilanalyse, wie funktioniert die? Weil es geht dabei darum, dass, also die DNA wissen ja vielleicht nicht alle. Da gibt es eben einige Teile, die nennen sich Gene. Die werden Gene genannt, weil sie kodieren für irgendwelche Eigenschaften oder für irgendwelche Proteine jedenfalls, weil sie Informationen eben weitergeben. Und der größte Teil der DNA ist aber eben, nach bisheriger Kenntnis, funktionslos. Und daraus erklärt man sich auch, dass dieser Teil der DNA sehr stark variiert zwischen den Menschen. Weil man eben sagt, Evolution, da gab es keinen Selektionsdruck, weil die keine Funktion haben, diese Teile. Und deswegen unterscheiden die sich im Grunde zwischen allen Menschen. Und zwar sind das eben, also sind es große Teile der DNA. Und da wiederum gibt es dann einzelne Basenpaare. Und die wiederholen sich. Und bei einem Menschen wiederholen die sich zweimal an der Selbststelle. Beim anderen Menschen wiederholen sie sich 15-mal. Und beim nächsten 35-mal. Das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Und auch die Kombination dieser verschiedenen Stellen auf der nicht kodierenden DNA ist sehr unterschiedlich. Und deswegen kann man eben ein individuelles Profiler stellen.
Also ich fasse nochmal zusammen. In der DNA gibt es die Sachen, die dafür zuständig sind, dass wir irgendwie blonde Haare, blaue Augen und was der Geier was haben. Und dann gibt es auch große Teile, die einfach sagen, also zumindest jetzt unbekannt keine Funktion haben, aber die bestimmten Mustern entsprechen. Und davon gibt es mehrere in einem Genom. Und die Kombination sozusagen daraus, wie diese verschiedenen Stellen aussehen, die keine sonstige Funktion haben, daraus kann man ablesen, zu wem das gehört.
Daraus kann man, genau. Das ist halt so, das sind einzelne Basenpaare. Wir haben ja Milliarden von Basenpaaren auf der DNA. Und das sind eben einzelne Stellen, wo man dann eben einen Basenpaar wiederholt sich so und so oft.
Und ist das sozusagen, also es gibt ja diese vier Basen, die sich da irgendwie verknüpfen, und das ist immer ein Spezielles, das sich da wiederholt? Oder sind das verschiedene auch?
Das sind verschiedene Kombinationen aus den vier Basenpaaren. Also das ist unterschiedlich. Welche Stellen da genau genommen wurden, ist auch, das hat sich so entwickelt, dass es allmählich im Prozess der Standardisierung haben sich da bestimmte Systeme. Wobei das jetzt verwirrend ist, hier von Basenpaaren zu reden, weil man bei Basenpaaren üblicherweise an die Watson-Crick-Paarung denkt. Also das hat jetzt nichts mit dem Doppelstrang zu tun, sondern es sind einfach zwei nebeneinander stehende Basen, die sich im Tandem, deswegen heißen die Short Tandem Repeats, im Tandem immer wiederholen. Genau, und das ist die Abkürzung STR, was wir vorhin hatten.
Okay, die versucht man also nachzuweisen, und was genau macht die langen Lichtsignale, die Länge dieser Basenpaare, die messen quasi einfach nur aus, wie lang das Basenpaar ist, was ich gerade suche.
Nein, nicht das Basenpaar, sondern was man wirklich misst, was das Merkmal ist, ist wie oft sich dieses Tandem, also wie viele von diesen kleinen Tandems es gibt, die da hintereinander stehen, und das ist wirklich das Merkmal. Die Sequenz interessiert einen nicht mal, und die wird auch nicht ausgelesen.
Okay, aber das ist schon mal ein interessanter Punkt für mich. Es wird also gar nicht diese ganzen, was man mit DNA eigentlich verbindet, nämlich diese ganzen Persönlichkeitsmerkmale herausgefunden, sondern es wird eigentlich nur ein bestimmtes Muster herausgefunden, und dann wird davon ausgegangen, dass es eine Person eindeutig identifiziert.
Genau, das hängt dann auch davon ab, wie viele Stellen analysiert werden. Also es gibt in Deutschland im Moment acht Stellen, die standardisiert so analysiert werden, und demnach ist die statistische Wahrscheinlichkeit dann eins, so weiß ich wie viele Millionen Menschen, dass genau dieses eine trifft, sozusagen ein Profil mit diesen acht Stellen nur so und so oft in der Bevölkerung vorkommt, und das ist dann sozusagen die Trefferwahrscheinlichkeit.
Ist die besser oder schlechter als Fingerabdrücke?
Also die Fingerabdrücke sind ja auch einmalig, das sagt man jedenfalls.
Na ja, da gibt es auch so Zahlen, das ist also auch bis eins zu irgendwas.
Da gibt es auch bestimmte Punkte, die man standardisiert anguckt, und da gibt es auch welche, die sich wiederholen, genauso ist es eben bei der DNA auch. Das hängt halt davon ab, wie viele Stellen werden analysiert, und wie viele sind wiederum in der Datenbank zur Verfügung, um das zu vergleichen, und je größer die Datenbanken werden, da werden wir auch noch zu kommen, desto öfter kann es halt auch vorkommen, dass es zwei Personen da eingespeichert sind, mit dem gleichen Profil. Und das nennt sich dann falsche Treffer.
Also das kann aber sozusagen nicht vorkommen. Also nur weil ich sozusagen jetzt die DNA in einem Tatort, sagen wir mal, gefunden habe, weiß ich noch nicht hundertprozentig, dass jeder andere, also jeder, den ich in Zukunft finde, dasselbe Profil hat, dass das auch der Typ ist.
Genau, das ist immer eine Wahrscheinlichkeitsberechnung. Und das hängt auch davon ab, wie viele eben, Loki nennt sich das auch, diese Stellen analysiert werden. Deswegen ist sozusagen die Maschinerie, je größer die Datenbanken sind, desto mehr Loki muss man auch wieder analysieren, um dahinter herzukommen, um nicht so viele falsche Treffer zu haben. Weil man sozusagen eine größere Vergleichsbevölkerung hat, muss man jetzt auch wieder hinterherziehen und mehr Stellen in der DNA analysieren. Und das wird im Moment ja auch europaweit vorgeschlagen, ist aber noch nicht überall durchgesetzt.
Jetzt habt ihr gerade gesagt, dass die Art und Weise, welche Stellen man da aussucht, unterscheidet sich. Gibt es einen wissenschaftlichen Standard, dass Leute mal herausgefunden haben, die und die Stelle nimmt man? Ist das dann unterschiedlich nach Land oder nach Polizeistelle?
Das hat sich unterschiedlich entwickelt, weil die Technik ist ja jetzt noch nicht so alt. Die ist ja irgendwie, glaube ich, 1983 oder so, hat der Alec Treffries diese Idee gehabt, bzw. hat das eben auch erstmalig umgesetzt. Und das hat sich dann tatsächlich erstmal relativ national entwickelt. Also auch diese Systeme. Und es gab dann Ende der 80er Jahre, gab es dann die erste europaweite Standardisierungseinrichtung, also so eine Gruppe von Forensikern, die eben versucht haben, diese Technik zu standardisieren. Damals war allerdings die Technik noch etwas anders als heute. Es ist zwar das selbe System, dass man eben genau eine Kombination untersucht. Also das ist vielleicht auch das, dass man sich dabei immer wieder klarmachen muss, dass es eben, also wenn ich jetzt nur zwei Stellen auf der DNA untersuchen würde, und die eine Stelle, da gibt es, was weiß ich, die Häufigkeit, dass sich ein so ein Short-Tandem-Repeat fünfmal wiederholt, das gibt es irgendwie bei 20 Prozent der Bevölkerung, also oder sagen wir, bei 10 Prozent der Bevölkerung. Also die Häufigkeiten sind ja unterschiedlich verteilt. Also natürlich gibt es viele Menschen, die an einer Stelle 15 Wiederholungen haben. Aber es gibt schon weniger Menschen, die an der einen Stelle 15 Wiederholungen, an der anderen Stelle 33 Wiederholungen haben. Und es gibt noch weniger Menschen, die an drei Stellen die gleiche Anzahl wiederholen.
Ja genau. Und die Frage sozusagen, gibt es jetzt eine Methode, die überall angewandt wird, oder geht es noch unterschiedlich nach wo?
Nach Land, unterschiedlich im Moment. Also unter Schili wurde das ja vorgeschlagen, dass man europaweit Datenbanken austauscht, DNA-Daten. Und da hat man sich von deutscher Initiative aus erst mal gepusht, dass sieben Stellen sozusagen jetzt gemeinsam verglichen werden. Und das ist wohl auch der Grund, warum zum Beispiel die britische Datenbank noch nicht sich eingespeist hat und sich da noch zurückhält, weil die die größte europaweite ist. Und den Moment, wo sieben Treffer sozusagen, also sieben Stellen in der DNA verglichen würden, europaweit mit diesen riesen Datenbanken, die es gibt, da würde es sehr viele falsche Treffer geben. Und das ist so ein bisschen, warum Scotland Yard und warum UK sich wohl da noch zurückhält, weil sie das Problem haben werden, dass sie diese vielen falschen Treffer immer wieder untersuchen müssen. Ist das wirklich relevant, diese Person, oder nicht? Was heißt das? Müssen wir jetzt ganz viel Daten abfragen von vielen Personen, die alle zu dieser Spur passen sozusagen. Und deswegen ist im Moment in Europa dann die Debatte, dass man halt jetzt standardisiert viel mehr Stellen in der DNA sozusagen speichern lassen will. Das dauert natürlich aber wieder, bis die neuen Spuren, neuen Personenprofile da wieder eingeschweißt sind. Und dementsprechend wird das noch eine Weile dauern. Aber das ist sozusagen, die Technik zieht dann immer wieder hinterher, mit je größer die Datenbanken werden. Und in Deutschland ist im Moment zum Beispiel hier in Berlin LKA und die Charité, die auch untersucht die forensische Abteilung, machen da inzwischen 17 Stellen, untersuchen die bei den neuen Spuren, die sie analysieren.
Und das wäre dann europaweit generalisiert? Also dann kann man mit jedem anderen Land in Europa reden und sagen, guck mal, ich habe hier DNA-Datenbanken.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie viele es sind. 13 oder so europaweit, glaube ich, weiß ich nicht genau, wie viele sich da geeignet haben.
Die Empfehlung von der EU liegt bei 17. Also das ist auch ein kommerzielles System, was eben jetzt angeboten wird. Das darf man dabei auch nicht vergessen, dass diese ganze Biometrie, also nicht nur DNA überhaupt, das ist ein riesengroßer Markt. Und da gibt es viele Anbieter. Und das ist auch ein Aspekt dabei, dass diese Technik auch immer weitergeht. Aber das ist ja überall so.
Okay, also das ist jetzt ganz schön viel auf einmal. Ich versuche das noch mal zusammenzufassen. Also man macht so ein DNA-Profil, in dem man bestimmte Stellen in der DNA-Probe anschaut und dann guckt, wie viele bestimmte Muster es an Basenpaaren dort gibt. Und das kann man an vielen verschiedenen Stellen machen. Das macht man anscheinend mit der modernsten Technik, sage ich mal, an 17 verschiedenen Stellen. Und das wird landesweit immer gleichgemacht, also in jedem europäischen Land. Und das Problem ist sozusagen, dass die Behörden sich nicht austauschen können, gerade weil sie verschiedene Stellen nehmen, weil es so viele davon gibt, die man beobachten kann.
Das ist ein Problem für die, nicht für uns unbedingt.
Na ja, genau so sagen. Okay, wie ist denn das? Jetzt haben wir das also irgendwie analysiert und anscheinend gibt es Interesse, die Datenbank anzulegen, davon haben wir die ganze Zeit schon gesprochen. Nach der Analyse, was passiert denn A mit der Probe und B mit den Daten?
Also die Daten, die Personenprofile, wie sich das nennt, wenn also Menschen aus bestimmten Gründen dazu aufgefordert sind oder auch zwangsweise vorgeführt werden, eine DNA-Probe abgeben zu müssen, um ihr Personenprofil in einer Datenbank, in der Datenbank des Bundeskriminalamtes nämlich, zu speichern. Das ist die eine Seite. Also es gibt eben diese Personenprofile, die gespeichert werden in der BKA-Datenbank, die es seit 1998 gibt. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es ja die Spurenprofile, wo eben noch keine Person zugeordnet ist, die halt von den Tatorten kommen. Und im Moment ist es so, dass da insgesamt 900.000 schon Profile in der BKA-Datenbank gespeichert sind. Also das wächst exponentiell auch, wie viel gespeichert wird. Und davon sind ein Großteil Personenprofile über 700.000. Und der Rest sind eben dann Spurenprofile. Aber was ist da genau drin? Das ist praktisch ein Computerchord, wo eben diese Zahlen, einfach diese Wiederholungszahlen, dieser Short Tandem Repeat, sozusagen immer ein Doppelpaar halt achtmal, einfach nur acht Doppelzahlen, also 16 Zahlen pro Person. Weil jede Stelle ja doppelt ist in der DNA, gibt es dann 16 Zahlen, die da für eine Person nur gespeichert sind.
Das sind dann aber nur acht Stellen, du sagst nicht die siebzehn.
Genau, im Moment ist es ja noch so. Einzelne Labore haben jetzt schon nachgezogen. Auch den Charité haben wir jetzt seit November 2010. Das ist bisher nur eine Empfehlung, das ist nicht standardisiert, das ist bisher rechtlich durchgesetzt.
Und was noch? Es hilft ja nichts, wenn da ein Datenmarkt voller Codes ist, sondern wahrscheinlich noch persönliche Daten.
Genau, dann kommen die persönlichen Daten dazu und sind wiederum mit den Ermittlungsakten verschaltet. Also kann man sich da sozusagen besorgen.
Was für persönliche Daten da drin stehen?
Das ist standardisiert, das weiß ich nicht genau, das sind erstmal die Namen und der persönlichen Geburtsort, Geburtsdatum, aber man kann dann praktisch die Akte damit anfordern. Dann ist es auch jetzt europaweit nicht so, dass da praktisch computerisiert diese Daten abgefragt werden, von einem Land zum anderen, sondern wird erstmal gefragt, gibt es jemand, gibt es anonymen sozusagen erstmal, oder Pseudonym eine Person, die das trifft? Und dann muss auf dem Rechtsweg ganz normal angefragt werden, auf dem Amtsweg, ob die Daten rausgerückt werden, bei den persönlichen Daten. Es gibt erstmal dieses No-Hit und No-Hit sozusagen.
Also ich bin sozusagen im Ausland und denke irgendwie, vielleicht ist der Typ, den ich hier gefunden habe, in Deutschland, frage ich die deutschen Behörden, also sagen, habt ihr in DNA-Profil das Folgen, in einem Code-Folge entspricht? Und wenn die Ja sagen, dann muss ich sozusagen auf dem offiziellen Rechtsweg irgendwie ersuchen, dass da die persönlichen Daten dazu rausgerückt werden. Und das soll jetzt geändert werden?
Also es gibt aber noch eine kurze Anmerkung am Rande, dass die Proben werden asserviert. Also wenn ich jetzt diese Spurprofile, die in der Datenbank auch gespeichert werden, da werden die dazugehörigen Proben, wenn es eben noch kein aufgeklärter Fall ist, die werden eben aufgehoben, weil man ja eben die dann für, wenn die Ermittlungen irgendwie vorangeht, vielleicht nochmal brauchen kann.
Bei den Personenprofilen ist es in Deutschland so, dass da praktisch dieser Speichel dann vernichtet wird. In anderen Ländern ist es auch wieder anders. Da wird praktisch die Probe auch erhalten, also in den Niederlanden zum Beispiel. Und da kann man dann sozusagen auch alles mögliche andere mit analysieren.
Wie vernichtet man so eine Speichelprobe, nur so im traditionellen Halbbereich?
Das probieren wir morgen mal aus. Ob man das überhaupt machen kann?
Da wird halt praktisch keine Biobank aufgebaut, um diese ganzen Mathe-Stiebchen dann sozusagen zu speichern.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt irgendwie Vorschriften, wie man eine Speichelprobe korrekt entsorgt.
Das wissen wir jetzt nicht.
So transparent ist das nicht.
Das ist überhaupt alles ziemlich untransparent.
Und aus diesem Zahlencode kann man tatsächlich auch nicht mehr rauslesen?
Was auch noch in Deutschland seit Neuestem gespeichert wird, ist das Geschlecht. Zusätzlich wird das Geschlecht analysiert, bzw. angegeben bei der Person, bei der man es weiß. Bei der Spur wird das analysiert und auch gespeichert.
Zu der Frage, ob man daraus wirklich nichts mehr sagen kann, ändert sich potenziell. Anfangs dachte man, diese STRs haben gar keine biologische Signifikanz. So überhaupt nicht. Inzwischen gibt es Studien, die sich zumindest nicht auf die Logik beziehen, die jetzt benutzt werden, in der Forensik, aber andere STR-Logik, die doch assoziiert sind mit irgendwelchen biologischen Funktionen und Phänotypen. Das heißt, es kann sich durchaus auch ändern.
Das andere Problem, das es auch noch gibt, ist, dass es in den USA inzwischen gemacht wird, dass die sogenannte Verwandten-Suche oder Family-Searching wird das da genannt. Das hat es in einem Massengentest-Fall hier auch schon gegeben in Deutschland, dass Teiltreffer gesucht werden. Das heißt, es wird gesucht, gibt es eine Person in der Datenbank, die teilweise übereinstimmt mit diesem Profil, was wir da haben. Und dann kann es eben sein, dass das darauf hindeutet, dass es ein direkter Verwandter ist. Das heißt, in den USA hat man dann in der Datenbank zum Beispiel einen Sohn oder einen Vater von jemand gefunden und daraufhin dann recherchiert, nach dessen Verwandten sozusagen, die gar nicht gespeichert waren. Das heißt, dass die Gefahr besteht, dass mit solchen Methoden dann eben nicht nur die Leute selbst gespeichert sind, sondern ihre gesamten direkten Verwandten eben auch, ersten Grades. Indirekt sozusagen.
Jetzt wissen wir jetzt schon mal grob, wie das funktioniert mit diesem DNA-Profiling. Spucke spielt eine ganz große Rolle. Wer das überhaupt darf und wer diese Datenbanken anlegt und wie man da rein und vielleicht auch wieder rauskommt, das klären wir gleich. Vorher machen wir das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Danach geht es hier weiter im Chaosradio mit Genom-Speichereien. Heute Chaosradio zu DNA-Speichereien, also genauer gesagt die DNA-Profile, die die Kriminalpolizei von euch nehmen darf und die dann in Datenbanken abgespeichert werden. Wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde schon mal geklärt, wie das überhaupt geht. Und um das zu tun, sind heute drei Leute zu Gast. Einerseits Silv vom Chaos Computer Club, hallo nochmal. Und Uta Wagenmann und Susanne Schultz vom Gen-Ethischen Netzwerk. So, dicht ans Mikrofon, sonst hört man euch nicht, das ist ganz wichtig hier beim Radio. Wir hatten wie gesagt schon geklärt, wie man das macht, dass da Speichelproben genommen werden oder auch Hautabrieb, also alles was vom Körper so runterfällt, das kann man dafür benehmen, um ein DNA-Profil zu erstellen. Wir haben auch schon geklärt, dass es da nicht darum geht, um das ganze Genom zu entziffern, also im Sinne von zu wissen, ob jetzt jemand blaue Augen hat oder nicht, sondern es ist eigentlich nur so eine Art Identifizierungsmerkmal, was da benutzt wird. Was mich jetzt interessieren würde, ist der juristische Teil, wer darf denn eigentlich so ein DNA-Profil erstellen und wann darf der das machen?
Also das BKA darf Verlangen von Leuten, also sozusagen Zwangs vorgeführt werden, dürfen Leute, die mit einer richterlichen Anordnung oder auch wenn sie freiwillig eingewilligt haben, in einer Speicheprobe das machen müssen, weil sie eine Straftat von erheblicher Bedeutung einer beschuldigt werden oder auch verurteilt worden sind. Das Problem ist allerdings, wie immer, es ist so, dass die Ausweitung, es ist eine permanente Ausweitung, Halt, halt, halt, bevor wir zu dem Problem kommen, lass uns bitte erstmal klären, wie es funktioniert. Genau, ich erkläre deswegen, dass es funktioniert ist, seit 2005 eine Ausweitung gab, bei was als erhebliche Straftat gilt. Davor gab es auch schon einen ziemlich großen Straftatkatalog. Das war auch schon vorher nicht so, wie man manchmal denkt, dass es nur um Mord und Totschlag und Vergewaltigung ging, bei erheblicher Straftat von erheblicher Bedeutung. Aber seit 2005 ist es einfach so, dass jede Straftat als erhebliche Bedeutung gilt, wenn auch eine einfache kleinkriminelle Tat öfters wiederholt wurde. Das heißt, bei Wiederholungstaten, bei Diebstahl, und das ist inzwischen ein Großteil der Profile, die da aufgenommen werden, wenn gesagt wird, ja, das ist jemand, der wiederholt das bestimmt wieder, und ein Richter gibt eine Negativprognose vielleicht auch noch und sagt, ja, in der Zukunft wird das vielleicht auch noch so sein, der Fahrraddiebstahl wird bestimmt wiederholt, dann darf Zwangs vorgeführt werden. Es darf auch genommen werden, wenn Leute freiwillig einwilligen. Und das ist ein weiteres Problem, dass eben Leute offener...
Können wir kurz erstmal bei dem Zwangsding bleiben. Wie genau funktioniert das? Ich muss mir das so vorstellen wie so eine Hausdurchsuchung. Also die Polizei muss sich im Prinzip von irgendjemanden, Staatsanwaltrichter, irgendwas besorgen und geht dann hin und sagt, so Alter, jetzt kommst du vorbei und gibst meine DNA-Probe ab. Oder wie läuft das?
Die Person wird entweder beim Verhör zum Beispiel direkt dazu aufgefordert. Wenn die Person sagt, ich möchte eine richterliche Anordnung, dann wird das noch abgewartet. Sie kann dazu geladen werden, das zu machen. Und wenn sie es nicht macht, wird sie auch abgeholt, um das zwangsweise dann zu vollführen.
Okay, aber du sagst, das muss im Zweifel von dem Richter angeordnet werden, dass das passiert. Und das ist sagen, das passiert bei diesem Straftatenkatalog, den du gerade erklärt hast. Und dann gibt es auch sozusagen die andere Form, dass es freiwillig gemacht wird. Freiwillig heißt, ich komme jetzt nicht auf die Idee und sage so, heute gehe ich mal DNA-Profil abgeben. Was heißt denn freiwillig in diesem Zusammenhang?
Freiwillig in Anführungsstrichen, wie du es schon gezeigt hast, was man hier nicht sehen kann, ist einfach so, dass in einer Situation, Verhörsituation, die alle allermeisten Leute völlig eingeschüchtert sind und sagen, okay, und auch nichts wissen darüber, dass es eine richterliche Anordnung geben muss. Deswegen ist auch dieser Begriff genetischer Fingerabdruck irreführend, weil man denkt, wie die normale erkennungsdienstliche Behandlung, muss man jetzt auch noch die Speichelprobe abgeben. Und deswegen sagen bis 98 Prozent, die Datenschützer aller Leute geben, denn in dieser Situation, unter Druck, unter Angst, ihre Speichelprobe eben sogenannt freiwillig ab. Das ist das Problem. Aber eigentlich muss eine richterliche Anordnung geben. Und das ist auch wichtig darauf hinzuweisen, dass alle das wissen, dass man das verweigern kann und erst mal abwarten, dass ein Richter da seine Anordnung gibt. Und auch diese richterliche Anordnung kann man auch nochmal wieder in Frage stellen. Da gibt es auch Erfahrungen bis zur Verfassungsbeschwerde, die erfolgreich waren, dass die Amtsgerichte oft ganz schnell diese richterliche Anordnung geben und dass man sich dann auch dagegen noch wehren kann juristisch. Dass man das nicht machen will oder im Nachhinein die Probe eben löschen lassen möchte, bzw. den Code löschen lassen möchte.
Und das funktioniert?
Das ist natürlich ein riesiger Aufwand, aber es gibt einzelne Verfassungsbeschwerden, die waren erfolgreich. Andere werden abgewiesen vom Verfassungsgericht. Das ist auch wieder ein bisschen willkürlich, wie Gerichte dann auch so sind. Wann das geschieht und wann nicht. Aber es gab einige erfolgreiche Verfassungsbeschwerden.
Wobei mit dem Löschen ganz kurz mal möchte ich nur noch sagen, es ist wichtig zu wissen, dass es niemand überprüfen kann, ob die tatsächlich gelöscht werden. Und wir kennen das ja aus anderen Datenbeständen, die bei der Polizei vorhanden waren oder sind. Was ich erinnere, Ende der 80er Jahre, das ist schon lange her, gab es in Berlin mal so einen ganz großen Skandal, weil wirklich mehrere Millionen Datensetzer aus allen möglichen Verkehrsdelikten, die längst hätten gelöscht sein müssen, immer noch vorhanden waren. Und das kann man gerade bei der Polizei, glaube ich, immer wieder feststellen, dass doch Daten, die einmal da sind, irgendwie nicht so richtig zum Verschwinden gebracht werden.
Jetzt gibt es ja in Deutschland auch so einen Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Kann ich nachfragen, ob meine Daten da irgendwie gespeichert wurden und müssen mir die dann Auskunft geben?
Ja, man erfährt das ja sowieso von Anfang an. Wenn man eine Speicheprobe abgibt, weiß man auch, dass das gespeichert wird. Man muss auch darüber informiert werden. Man kann auch nachfragen, ob die schon gelöscht wurde oder nicht.
Dann müssen die Auskunft geben. Da gibt es ja manchmal bei diesen Sachen auch so verentscheidige Dinge, dass wir können es nicht sagen, weil Ermittlungen in Gefahr sind. Aber die müssen sagen, ob sie von den einen haben oder nicht.
Genau, das haben auch Rechtsanwälte. Es gibt viel Kritik, dass Rechte nicht eingehalten werden, aber da haben wir bisher noch nicht so viel gehört. Das ist das Problem.
Um mal ein Zeilenverhältnis zu nennen, das BKA gibt ja immer Statistiken raus, wie viel sie eben gespeichert haben. Die Datenbank gibt es ja eben seit 1998. Da sind jetzt über 900.000 Datensätze drin, 920.000. Seit 1998 sind 177.000 Datensätze wieder gelöscht worden. Das ist allerdings nicht aufgeschlüsselt nach Spuren und Personendatensätzen, weil es gibt Löschfristen. Ich glaube, die liegen mehr 15 Jahre oder 10. Bei Erwachsenen, bei Kindern, bei Jugendlichen. Spurndatensätze werden dann auch irgendwann gelöscht, wenn ein Ermittlungsverfahren abgeschlossen ist und eine Verurteilung stattgefunden hat oder eine Einstellung. Bei einer Einstellung nicht, das ist Quatsch. Aber wenn der Fall geklärt ist und rechtskräftig ist, dann werden die Spuren nicht mehr weiter aufgehoben.
Wo gerade Kinder und Erwachsene fielen, ist das eigentlich so? Ich würde ja eigentlich annehmen, bei DNA ändert sich nicht, sondern bleibt das Leben gleich. A stimmt es und B gibt es einen Unterschied zwischen Kindern und Erwachsenen. Also ändert sich da noch mal was, dass sich dieser Identifikationsmerkmal verschieben kann?
Nee, also so weit ich weiß.
Also wenn man sich nicht länger in Fukushima aufgehalten hat und keine Knochenmarkspende bekommen hat, eher nicht.
Knochenmarkspende? Da spielst du auf die Chimären. Zu den Chimären kommen wir gleich noch, das ist auch sehr interessant. Menschliche Chimären, genau das war das Stichwort. Vorher noch kurz, es gibt also diesen Einzelfall, der relativ leicht nachvollziehbar ist. Irgendjemand wird beschuldigt und soll das dann abgeben, möglicherweise durch einen Richter beschlossen. Aber möglicherweise ist doch so eine Geschichte, dass es das macht. Es gibt ja noch einen zweiten Fall, wie diese DNA-Profil zustande kommt. Das sind diese Massentests. Wie sieht das denn rechtlich da aus? Darf der einfach so angeordnet werden? Oder ist das eigentlich auch eine freiwillige Sache? Wie funktioniert das?
Der Massentest ist freiwillig, also Richter muss ihn anordnen. Die Polizei muss sagen, die und die Kriterien brauchen wir. Und sozusagen tausend Leute oder die Leute in der Gegend, die diesen Kriterien entsprechen, müssen eben dann auch von dem und dem Alter vielleicht auch noch ein anderes Kennzeichen, was ich Autokennzeichen oder dies und das.
Also, warte, kurze Nachfrage. Es ist also so, die sagen nicht einfach, in der Region wird ein Massentest gemacht, sondern die müssen schon sagen, also in dieser Region möchten wir von allen Leuten, auf die die und die Merkmale zutreffen, ein DNA-Profil.
Genau, das muss ein Richter anordnen und dann ist es freiwillig daran teilzunehmen. Das hat offiziell auch wieder freiwillig. Natürlich gibt es auch wieder einen ganz schönen Druck. Gerade in ländlichen Regionen haben wir gehört, dass fast alle Leute dann unter Druck stehen, dass sie eben die Speichelprobe da abgeben. Und eigentlich ist es auch so, wenn man sich verweigert, dass daraus einem kein Nachteil erwachsen soll. Aber es gibt immer wieder Beispiele, wo eben nur sehr wenige das verweigert haben und dann unter Druck geraten sind oder auch unter Ermittlungen gekommen sind und dann eben weitergeguckt wird, was ist mit denen und warum haben sie das gemacht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also ich als Polizist würde sagen, so okay, die drei Leute da wollen die Probe nicht abgeben, die sind erstmal verdächtig.
Genau, das passiert auch immer wieder. Dann kann man zwar, es gab mal einzelne Fälle, wo dann auch zwangzwangs angeordnet werden soll, dass sie die Speichelprobe abgeben. Das ist aber nicht rechtens. Aber das hat es in einzelnen Fällen, haben Datenschützer das auch moniert. Das darf aber nicht sein. Da muss wenn dann schon ein ganz anderer Anfangsverdacht da sein. Aber es ist natürlich klar, dass unter Umständen die Leute dann genauer angeguckt werden. Dagegen kann man dann auch wenig machen, wenn es nur ganz wenige sind. Dass dann die Polizei sich die anguckt und alles mögliche andere. Da muss sie auch dann gewichtige Gründe haben, warum sie die Person zur Speichelprobe dann zertiert. Dann müssen sie formal beschuldigen.
Wo ich dann aber auch fragen würde, es ist ja jetzt nicht schlimm, also irgendwie so den Verdächtigen zu fassen, ist ja dann auch eine gute Sache. Oder sehe ich das falsch?
Ich weiß nicht, wer will antworten. Also wir sagen erstmal, dass die Ermittlungen jetzt in Bezug auf Mord, Vergewaltigung, dass wir da jetzt eher das nicht so problematisch sehen, wie diese Massen an Daten, die wegen Kleinkriminalität erhoben werden. Wir finden es aber problematisch, dass Leute sozusagen unter sozialem Gedruck gesetzt werden, da eben dann doch nicht freiwillig, sondern unfreiwillig Daten abzugeben, von denen sie dann schlecht überprüfen können, was mit denen weiter geschieht. Und das ist ein Teil von vielen Datensätzen, die inzwischen eben in staatlichen Behörden gesammelt werden.
Das meinte ich jetzt gerade nicht, sondern ich meinte, es gibt diesen Massengentest und ein paar Leute nehmen nicht teil und werden dann sozusagen beobachtet, weil sie sich quasi verdächtig gemacht haben. Das ist ja jetzt nachvollziehbar, finde ich zumindest, also könnte man so sehen, dass man die dann genauer beobachtet, wenn die ja offensichtlich was zu verbergen haben. Und das findet ihr nicht, oder?
Also ich finde das zum Beispiel solange sehr problematisch, wie ich als Bürgerin nicht überprüfen kann, ob zum Beispiel diese Daten eines Massengentests, die nicht gespeichert werden dürfen, das ist ganz klar, also gebietet das Gesetz. Ich habe keinerlei Möglichkeit, das zu überprüfen. Die Polizei ist ein Apparat in sich, wo ich wenig Einblick drin habe. Solange ich das nicht überprüfen kann, solange es keine ausführlichen Berichtspflichten der Polizei gibt und auch Nachweise und auch eine unabhängige Stelle, die das regelmäßig überprüft, habe ich da so meine Zweifel. Ich bin sehr misstrauisch, was die Polizei anbelangt. Du hast völlig recht, wenn du sagst, es ist eine Vergewaltigung passiert. Das ist ja meistens bei Kapitalverbrechen, also bei Mord oder so, dass diese Massengentests angeordnet werden. Die werden nicht bei Liebstahl angeordnet. Das ist ganz klar. Ich traue dieser Geschichte nicht, weil ich einfach weiß, dass die Polizei nach Daten hungert. Ich will die nicht bezichtigen, aber solange es keine geregelte Überprüfung und unabhängige Überprüfung der Polizei gibt, gehe ich da erst mal eher von negativen Entwicklungen aus und traue dem nicht über den Weg. Dann finde ich es eben sehr problematisch, wenn Leute, die einfach ihre Daten nicht abgeben wollen, was es zwar heutzutage selten gibt, aber es gibt es ja, wenn die dann sagen, ich mache da nicht mit und dadurch automatisch unter Verdacht geraten. Das ist auch eine Umkehrung der Unschuldsvermutung, die ja eine Grundlage des Rechtsstaates eigentlich ist. Ich rede jetzt mal so aus meinem juristischen Leinenverstand. Aber das ist tatsächlich eine Grundlage. Man geht erst mal von der Unschuld der Leute aus und das wird da im Grunde umgekehrt. Und das finde ich problematisch, solange es eben nicht eine Transparenz gibt, die tatsächlich auch regelmäßig überprüft wird.
Die ja auch niemals vollständig nachvollziehbar wäre. Ein anderer Punkt, den ihr gerade gesagt habt, die von diesen Massen-Gentests, müssen die Daten alle gelöscht werden?
Nein, die dürfen nicht in dieser zentralen BKA-Datenbank eingespeichert werden, sondern in extra Dateien. Und da können sie theoretisch auch unendlich lange bleiben, solange der Fall nicht aufgeklärt ist. Das heißt, sie dürfen solange gespeichert werden, solange sie noch von Nöten sind. Das ist auch so eine ganz schwammige Formulierung. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie sie im Gesetz steht, aber im Grunde müssen die erst wirklich gelöscht werden, wenn der Fall eindeutig aufgeklärt ist.
Und dann sozusagen nur die von den Leuten, die überführt wurden, die davon haben behalten und der Rest muss alles weg?
Genau.
Alle Unschuldigen quasi. Okay, das kann man aber natürlich nicht nachfragen. Wie sind die jetzt auf diese 800.000 gekommen, die da jetzt gerade drin sind?
900.000.
Das sind alles Einzelfälle.
Man muss da vielleicht auch nochmal die Geschichte sehen von der DNA-Datenbank. Das hat ja angefangen mit so einer Errichtungsanordnung. Dann gab es das erste Gesetz. Und die ersten Jahre, bis 2005 im Grunde, wurden die Altfälle abgearbeitet. Das hat das Gesetz damals auch vorgesehen, das Vorgängergesetz. Sämtliche Leute, die wegen Straftaten eines Straftatenkatalogs, was Susanne vorhin schon mal kurz zusammengefasst hat, sind eben wirklich nachträglich zu einer DNA-Probe gezwungen worden. Das Gesetz hat zwar vor, dass es einen Richter beschließen muss bzw. anordnen muss. Es gab auch immer eine richterliche Anordnung, die aber über sehr viele Jahre einfach nur den Gesetzestext zitiert hat. Denn Bedingung für diese Entnahme bei den Strafgefangenen war, dass es eine Wiederholungsgefahr besteht. Das heißt, eine negative Prognose. Und die Richter haben das immer einfach standardmäßig im Grunde rausgeschickt. Da sind sie dann auch vom Verfassungsgericht ziemlich für abgewatscht worden. Das war also nicht verfassungsgemäß. Trotzdem waren die Daten natürlich dann schon da. Diese Altfelder sind eben erstmal abgearbeitet worden. Und seit 2005, seit es eben dieses Gesetz gibt, von dem Susanne vorhin geredet hat, was eben einfach grundsätzlich bei Wiederholungsgefahr die Speichel, also die Entnahme einer Speichelprobe und die Erstellung eines DNA-Profils und Speicherung in der Datenbank erlaubt, seit es dieses Gesetz gibt, ist die Zahl der sogenannten Bagatelldelikte total angestiegen. Also auch nochmal als Zahl von den Treffern, die es gibt, sind wirklich 80.000 oder 75.000 sind Diebstahldelikte. Das ist der Delikt, der am allermeisten benutzt wird in der DNA-Datenbank. Also nicht etwa Mord oder Totschlag oder Vergewaltigung, was ja immer alle Leute denken. Woran sie immer denken, weil sie so viel Tatort gucken.
Das macht so ungefähr 70 Prozent aus.
Die 900.000 sind nicht einfach 900.000 Personenprofile, oder? Sind da auch Spuren dabei? Und die Spuren können ja mehrere von einem Tatort. Das heißt, da kommen wahrscheinlich pro Fall schon mehrere zusammen. Also es sind jetzt nicht 900.000 Personen, die da drin sind.
Das sind über 700.000 Personen. Über 700.000 Personen und 180.000 Spuren. Also es sind schon mehr Personen als Spuren.
Jetzt haben wir einen Anrufer, und zwar den Jörg aus Meißen. Und der hat mal bei so einem Massengentest mitgemacht. Das finde ich sehr spannend. Hallo Jörg, guten Abend. Wie ist es dazu gekommen, dass du so einen Massengentest mitmachen musstest?
Also das war so ungefähr vor vier, fünf Jahren war das. Da stand ein Polizist in Zivil vor Wurziger und hat gesagt, na ja, wir suchen einen Vergewaltiger. Sie haben es sicher aus den Nachrichten, aus den Lokalen mitbekommen. Ich habe da nichts gehört. Und ja, den Gentest, wir würden das gleich mal schon machen und so. Und sie hätten ja nichts dagegen. Und die Probe wird auch vernichtet dann irgendwann. Oder hat ihm ein Zettel noch gekämen, den musste ich schon unterschreiben. Ich bin da eigentlich relativ offen. Ich habe ihn reingelassen und habe gesagt, na gut, es dient ja der Sache. Wird ja die Ermittlungen da nicht irgendwie benachteiligen. Und hat dann den Gent diesen Test gemacht. Hat mich auch dahin gewiesen, dass man nicht bloß speichelt, sondern wirklich hier diese Schleimhautzellen sozusagen mussten wirklich auch mit drin sein, hat er mir extra gesagt. Ja, das war eigentlich die ganze Sache. Und ich hab dann auch im Nachhinein überlegt, diese Speichelprobe ist ja das eine. Aber die Daten, die sind ja dauerhaft gespeichert, wie das die Leute vorhin schon gesagt haben. Das wird so sein.
Die sind da, um das ganz genau zu verstehen, die haben bei dir an der Tür geklingelt quasi? Und hatten ein offizielles Schreiben dabei? Oder haben die einfach nur gesagt, wir müssten hier mal?
Na ja, ich hätte ihn eigentlich gar nicht reinlassen sollen. Aber wie gesagt, er war in Zivil und hat auch seine Pflicht gemacht, so wie es mir schien. Und eine Kopie von irgendwas hat er da gehabt. Letztendlich hat er sich nicht ausgewiesen. Ich habe nicht gesagt, er sollte sich das zwingend ausweisen vor mir.
Du hast doch nicht das Ding gesehen, wo genau drin steht, warum er das macht, also diese Anordnung?
Ich habe in einem Schreiben auf dem Tisch, das hat er mir da gelassen, da habe ich unterschrieben, das habe ich als Kopie auch noch da gehabt. Leider habe ich es irgendwann mal weggeschmissen, dass ich mir das eigentlich ausheben soll, weil das stand eben drin, dass die Probe vernichtet wird, das stand drin. Da habe ich mir gedacht, wenn die Probe vernichtet wird, dann ist die Sache für mich eigentlich erledigt.
Würdest du das noch mal machen?
Im Nachhinein ist immer das Problem, wenn man die Gradwanderung, wie ihr vorhin schon gesagt habt, wenn ich es nicht mache, dann mache ich mich quasi gleich verdächtig, das ist ja so. Und ich würde es eigentlich noch mal machen. Und ich vermute auch damals war das Problem, die haben gesagt, ich war damals ledig gewesen und habe bestimmt das Alter gehabt. Die haben gesagt, okay, alle ledigen, die bestimmt das Alter haben in dem Umkreis, die sind halt zu testen, vermute ich mal so.
Und das stört dich aber schon, dass du dich verdächtig gemacht hast, nur weil du das ablehnst, oder findest du das in Ordnung, dass das so läuft?
Damals war ich da noch nicht ganz so sensibilisiert, was diesen ganzen Datenschutz betrifft, was ich heutzutage ein bisschen mehr bin. Und damals habe ich, wie ein normaler Mensch, auch gedacht, wenn es zur Sache dient, und Vergewaltiger sind ja immer schlimm, wie man das immer, dass viele Sachen werden auch festgemacht. Ein Vergewaltiger und Kinderschänder, das ist heutzutage leider so. Habe ich halt gemacht, ja.
Und Gottverdammt, wir haben verloren.
Ich finde es ein Unding, dass Sie das einen Hausbesuch gemacht haben, also dass Sie das nicht die Leute geladen haben.
Ich dachte mir gerade, dass wir das eigentlich auch mal machen könnten, oder? Also einfach so von Haustür zu Haustür gehen, Sonneborn-Style.
Schickt uns alle eure Speichelproben. Ach so, genau was ich fragen wollte. Hast du mal mit dem Gedanken gespielt, noch mal die Polizei anzuschreiben und zu fragen, ob die Informationen von dir haben, also das quasi einfach mal anzufordern?
Ihr habt ja vor uns gesagt, dass es geht, dass man in der Ziepze Informationen anfordern kann, ob das denn alles rechtens ist. Aber da ich ja nichts habe, keinen Zettel, wann das gewesen ist und wer das auch gewesen ist, ja.
Das spielt dafür aber keine Rolle.
Du kannst einfach sozusagen, also soweit ich es vermitteln, kannst du nach diesem Informationsfreies Gesetz einfach sagen, so mein Name ist so und so, ich wohne da und da, bitte schicken Sie mir alle Daten, die Sie über mich gespeichert haben und dann müssen Sie eigentlich antworten. Da gibt es bei den meisten Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten auch extra ein Formular vorschreiben, die du quasi noch ausfüllen und hinschicken musst, zumindest für die offiziellen staatlichen Stellen.
Aber das ist auch wieder die Frage der Kriminalist, der einen Fall lösen muss, hat jetzt irgendeinen Namen auf dem Schirm. Mein zum Beispiel. Und guckt erst mal, was liegt denn an? Geschwindigkeitsübertretung irgendwann mal. Und dann sieht er meinetwegen, aha, hat Anfrage gestellt, ob da ein Satz vorhanden ist. Das macht mich auch wieder verdächtig. Das ist überall die Sache.
Naja, das zeigt aber schon sehr gut, dass eine der Kritiken hier zum Tragen kommt, die das genetische Netzwerk auch hat, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, nämlich der Sozialdruck, der dadurch entsteht, dass es diese Technik überhaupt gibt. Also der scheint bei dir richtig gut zu funktionieren.
Naja, das scheint zu funktionieren.
Alles klar. Jörg, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf und für die Geschichte. Bitte, bitte. So, interessant, das mal von jemandem zu hören, der das selber mitgemacht hat. Wenn euch das ähnlich geht, könnt ihr gerne auch noch hier anrufen. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer dafür. Was ratet ihr denn eigentlich Leuten, die so einem Gentest jetzt angefragt werden? Also klar, es ist aus dem, was ihr jetzt gesagt habt zu vermuten, ihr sagt, so macht es nicht. Aber habt ihr irgendwie Hinweise, wie Leute mit genau diesem Druck, den Jörg gerade geschildert hat, umgehen sollen? Also wie man das auf die Reihe kriegt, das ist auch unangenehm.
Das ist zivilcourage, da können wir auch weiter jetzt nicht zu sagen, als andere Leute zu informieren im Umfeld und sagen, dass man das Recht hat auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung und dass es offiziell freiwillig ist. Und dass es freiwillig an einem massengehten Test teilzunehmen und dass es keinen Grund gibt, warum man da teilnehmen muss, wenn man gewisse Zweifel hat, was mit seinem Daten passiert und lieber die es gar nicht abgeben möchte.
Das Schuldgefühl wird einem natürlich eingepflanzt, dass man dann an der Ermittlung nicht teilnimmt oder so was. Aber ich finde auch, dass man sich da tatsächlich immer wieder versuchen muss, mit sich selber da irgendwie ins Reine zu kommen und zu sagen, nee, wieso, ich habe es nicht gemacht und ich will damit nichts zu tun haben. Kann man dann auch ein bisschen im Kontext setzen, dass nicht selten mal solchen Massen-Gen-Tests, die einfach gar nicht zum Ergebnis führen, oder dann der Fall durch ganz normale klassische Polizeiarbeit gelöst wird. Also es ist nicht so, dass dann deinetwegen, wenn du da nicht hingehst, der Kinderschänder davonkommt.
Ja, das ist auch ein ganz wichtiger Hinweis.
Aufklärungsquote durch DNA-Profile, na dann mal los hier. Graben auf den Tisch, wie viele?
Da gibt es eben überhaupt keine Statistik drüber.
Gar keine?
Also das ist das Interessante, dass das BKA eben durchaus genau auflistet, welche, in welchen Delikten eben Treffer, Treffer gegeben hat. Spur-Spur-Treffer gibt es ja eben, was, wie ich vorhin gesagt habe.
Das Spur-Spur heißt zu sagen, ich habe an zwei verschiedenen Orten dieselbe DNA gefunden, weiß aber nicht, wer es ist.
Berühmteste ist ja das Phantom von Heilborn. Aber ich will dir jetzt kein Stichwort geben, das wolltest du eher selber.
Genau, machen wir später nochmal.
Auf jeden Fall, das wird alles relativ genau aufgelistet. Es wird aber überhaupt nicht gesagt. Es gibt eben auch Personenspurentreffer. Wie viele gab es insgesamt, seit es die Datei gibt. Aber es wird nicht gesagt, wie hoch ist eigentlich die Aufklärungsrate durch Massengen-Tests, durch DNA-Tests und so weiter. Und das ist einfach eine Frage, die im Raum steht und die natürlich sich jeder Mensch fragt, der sich damit ein bisschen beschäftigt. Wie hoch ist eigentlich wirklich die Aufklärungsrate? In Großbritannien gab es da ja glaube ich auch sehr viel zu.
Wir stehen im Kontakt mit GeneWatch, eine Organisation, die dort diese riesige Datenbank kritisiert. Die haben sich einfach mal die Fälle angeguckt, die in den Medien so kommen. Diese Mordfälle wurden durch DNA aufgeklärt und haben sämtliche Fälle, die da immer in den Medien auftauchen, demontiert, ganz besonders einen, wo auch am Ende die konservative Presse, die da immer für Sicherheit und für DNA-Datenbanken war, auch zugegeben hat, dass dieser Fall eben nicht durch DNA aufgeklärt wurde. Auch wenn es mal Statistiken gibt, DNA spielte in Fällen eine Rolle, dann ist es ganz oft so, dass es ein zusätzliches Verfahren noch war, aber das eigentlich die ganz normale polizeiliche Ermittlungsarbeit dazu geführt hat, die Leute zu überführen und dass dann auch ein zusätzlicher Beweis sozusagen war.
Okay, also wir halten fest zu sagen, das zieht einmäßige Ha-Ha, eine Blutspur. Wir wissen, wer der Mörder ist, das funktioniert schon mal nicht. Und das andere ist, also Stellen, die normalerweise nicht verlegen sind, mit Statistiken zu winken und zu sagen, hier guck mal, das ist alles total super, haben noch keine Statistik veröffentlicht, die belegt, wie man mit DNA-Profilen super Fell aufklärt. Das kann zumindest mal skeptisch machen.
Also das BKA schreibt es ganz konkret tatsächlich so, sie haben so und so viele Treffer gehabt und sagen dann eben, dass damit vermutlich eine Tat aufgeklärt wurde.
Vermutlich.
Das sagen sie auf ihrer Website. Also von daher kann man wirklich fragen, wie viele sind es denn wirklich?
Vermutlich. Also vielleicht gibt es da draußen jemanden, der bei so etwas mitgemacht hat, also sagen auf der Seite der Polizisten, mal die aus dem Liegkästchen plaudern will, 0371 77 97 110 ist die Nummer dafür. Die hat jetzt auch Uwe angerufen, der will noch was zu Jörg sagen, der gerade an so einem Massentest mitgemacht hat, bzw. darüber erzählt hatte. Und Uwe, du hast auch mitgemacht.
Ich bin von Berufswegen renettent. Ich bin nämlich Rechtsanwalt. Und mir ist einfach Befolgendes widerfahren. In meiner ehemaligen Heimat ist im Jahre 1992 ein Sexualmord geschehen, der über viele Jahre nicht aufgeklärt werden konnte. Im Laufe der Jahre hat dann das BK verschiedene Profile über den Täter erstellt. Unter anderem das letzte, von dem ich Kenntnis habe, war, der Täter ist zwischen, also männlich, bei einem Sexualmord zwischen 19 und 49 Jahre alt, oder 18 und 49 Jahre alt. Und hat seinen Wohnsitz, weil Ortskenntnis in dem Fall eine Rolle spielte innerhalb der drei angrenzenden Landkreise, die an dem Tatort angrenzten. Mit diesem Profil hat ein Staatsanwalt beim Gericht die Anordnung eines freiwilligen Massengentests beantragt. Und auch bekommen. Das führte dazu, dass viele Leute, auf die das Profil zutraf, angeschrieben wurden und gebeten wurden, freiwilligen Gentests abzugeben oder eine Genprobe abzugeben. Unter anderem war ich dabei. Ich habe als erstes das Briefchen weggepackt und mir gedacht, ihr könnt mich mal. Damit war es aber leider nicht getan. Irgendwann kriegte ich Post vom Amtsgericht in dem drin stand, lieber Herr Eichel, wir fordern dir auf, die Probe freiwillig abzugeben. Wenn du es nicht machen wirst, werden wir es durch Gerichtsbeschluss festlegen. Dann darfst du freiwillig gezwungen deine Genprobe abgeben.
Das ist schön. Ich möchte es in Ihrer Stelle noch mal sagen, dass man auf die Worte achtet. Wir möchten Sie auffordern, die Probe freiwillig abzugeben.
Nein, das war jetzt meine Wortwahl. Ich wurde ultimativ aufgefordert, eine Speichelprobe abzugeben, weil ansonsten gerichtlich eine Blutentnahme festgelegt würde oder angeordnet werden würde zum Zwecke der Genfeststellung.
Was würdest du denn jetzt sagen Leuten empfehlen, denen das innische blüht? Was würdest du denn jetzt Leuten empfehlen, denen das auch blüht? Also diese sagen...
Renitent bleiben, nicht freiwillig.
Hast du es dann durchgezogen?
Ich habe es durchgezogen. Wie gesagt, von Berufs wegen bin ich Renitent. Ich habe mich natürlich gewehrt und mich mit der Sache beschäftigt. Das heißt mir nicht dagegen, dass ein Amtsgericht, das Amtsgericht in Strahlund, die Entnahme von Blut zum Zwecke der Genfeststellung anordnete. Dagegen sind wir dann in Rechtsmitte gegangen mit der Begründung, Leute guckt mal ins Gesetz, schaut mal nach, was da drin steht. Ihr habt mir mitgeteilt, ihr seid du, lieber Uwe, bist kein Täter, sondern du bist unbeteiligter. Und du musst nur abgeben, wenn du es freiwillig tust. Und das kann ja wohl nicht rechtens sein, wenn ihr sagt, es ist freiwillig, dass ihr mich dann dazu zwängt, Blut abzugeben.
Wie ist es geendet?
Es ist letztendlich wie das Hornberger Schießen geendet. Die Staatsanwaltschaft, da muss ich mal einfach auf einiges hinweisen. Die Gerichte machen sich in solchen Fällen relativ einfach. Dazu muss man wissen, dass diese Gehengeschichten ein relativ neues Rechtsgebiet sind. Und in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren gab es eine Menge Rechtsänderungen, die zu dem jetzigen Zustand, dem jetzigen Gesetzeszustand geführt haben. Und die Begründung, die das Amtsgericht dafür gab, waren zwei Urteile von westdeutschen Landgerichten, die zu einem Zeitpunkt getroffen worden sind, zu dem der jetzige Rechtszustand gar nicht mehr noch gar nicht geführt ist.
Uwe, ich muss dich kurz unterbrechen. Wir wollen uns nicht in juristischen Feinheiten verlieren. Kannst du nur kurz und knapp sagen, wie es aussieht, was du daraus ziehst und was du empfehlen würdest, und vor allen Dingen noch mal kurz erklären, wie es ausgegangen ist?
Ausgegangen ist es so, dass das Landgericht nicht gesagt hat, ihr durftet die Anordnung gar nicht machen. Weil die freiwillige Abgabe in dem Fall nicht in Rede steht, sondern weil du hier gezwungen wirst, sondern das Landgericht sagte in diesem Fall, naja, es ist ja nicht ersichtlich, dass da irgendein Zusammenhang existiert. Die Gefahr, die ich einfach als Jurist dabei sehe, die hat mein Vorredner schon gesagt, wenn man sich weigert, ganz bestimmt freiwillig an so einem Gen-Test teilzunehmen, dann wird man irgendwann mal, solange man freiwillig gebeten wird, ist man noch nicht der Beschuldigte. Als Beschuldigten kann einem zwangsweise in die Gen-Probe abgenommen werden. Solange man nicht Beschuldigter ist, muss man es freiwillig tun. Und irgendwann kippt das um. Wenn man in dem Fall, in dem ich involviert war, insgesamt 6.500 Männern, die DNA-Profile überprüfen wurden, stellt sich letztendlich die Frage, es haben zu dem Zeitpunkt 6.600 Leute dort gewohnt. Wo kippt das um? Wo wird man dann Beschuldigter? Wenn dann nur noch fünf DNA-Proben übrig sind, oder wenn nur noch eine übrig bleibt, die noch nicht ausgewertet ist. Oder da ist ein juristischer Fallstück, der dann irgendwann mal von der...
Okay, also dass Sie sagen, das ist juristisch noch ungeklärt, das müsste sich wahrscheinlich jemand beschäftigen, der richtige Ahnung hat. Vermutlich ist es dann wieder das Bundesverfassungsgericht. Die oberen Gerichte haben ja in letzter Zeit häufiger mal so eine Dinge geklärt. Uwe, auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für deine Geschichte. Das ist ja auch mal sehr spannend zu hören, wie sich dann jemand, der sagen, im Gebiet, der mit beschäftigt, dagegen gewehrt hat. Und das scheint ja auch funktioniert zu haben. Es geht hier gerade um DNA-Speicherei. Und wir machen jetzt eine ganz kurze Pause, bevor es damit weitergeht. Und ja, wir sind gleich wieder da. Jonathan Coulton ist das und das ist Creative Commons Musik und That Spells DNA heißt der Track und hat eine sehr witzige Entstehungsgeschichte des Magazin Popular Science. Hat nämlich eine Artikelserie gemacht zum menschlichen Körper und hat ihn gefragt, ob er zu jedem dieser Artikel da ein Lied auch schreiben kann. Das hat er dann auch gemacht und hat das Ganze auch unter Creative Commons gestellt und beides passt hier sehr gut zusammen, denn ihr seid im Chaosradio gelandet, wo es heute um Genomspeichereien geht. Also darum, warum die Behörden so unsere ganzen Genome speichern wollen und was damit so anfangen und ob das vielleicht eine gute Idee ist. Wir haben jetzt schon geklärt, irgendwie wie man das macht, also was da genau rausgezogen wird aus dem DNA, wie man das technisch macht, wer das überhaupt darf, was da gespeichert wird und haben auch schon erfahren, dass es diese Massengentests gibt, wo man sich verdächtig macht, wenn man nicht dran teilnimmt, obwohl das alles freiwillig ist. Also dem Gesetzestext zur Folge. Zu Gast beim Chaosradio sind, um das heute alles zu klären, Sil vom Chaos Computer Club. Hören Sie noch zu?
Immer noch.
Und Uta Wagenmann und Susanne Schultz vom Gen-Ethischen Netzwerk. Hallo, hier auch noch mal.
Wir hören noch zu.
Sehr schön. Und jetzt geht es die ganze Zeit um diesen Datensatz, den man aus dem Genom herauslesen kann. Und es klingt halt so, die Kritik ist, diese Daten werden zu viel übernommen. Und man möchte das eigentlich gar nicht. Und es gibt aber auch Leute, die die Genomen freiwillig untersuchen lassen. Es ist nicht ganz dasselbe, wie wenn die Kriminalzeit bei dir zukommt, aber es passt gut genug zum Thema, um mal so jemanden zu befragen. Und so jemand ist in diesem Fall auch der Mensch, der dieses Lied empfohlen hat, das gerade lief, Martin Pittenauer, der jetzt am Telefon ist und sich sein Genomal hat untersuchen lassen. Hallo und guten Abend.
Moin Moin. Ja, also ich muss gleich dazusagen, vorneweg der genetischen Fingerabdruck und den quasi gezwungenermaßen freiwillig abgeben zu müssen, das halte ich für ein perfides Instrument, also da wäre ich jetzt auch nicht Freund davon.
Das ist nachvollziehbar bei dem, was man alles gehört hat. Aber trotzdem spannend ist zu sagen, es gibt doch noch eine andere Anwendung fürs Genom, nämlich man kann das abgeben und dann wird es untersucht. Du hast das machen lassen, du hast dafür Geld bezahlt, ich glaube, das ist auch nicht ganz billig.
Ja, es kostet so 100 Dollar einmalig und dann irgendwie für ein Jahr bist du dann in so einem Subscription Service drin, da gibt es mehrere Firmen, die das mittlerweile machen, in Amerika vor allem, weil die Rechtslage halt ein bisschen einfacher ist. Und an sich hat es mich halt interessiert. Ich habe schon immer so ein Interesse ein bisschen für Humanbiologie. Ich habe auch so ein Nebenfach technisch ein bisschen in die Richtung studiert und habe gesehen, dass es mittlerweile relativ billig so ein bisschen mit dem eigenen Genom Spaß zu haben. Und habe mir dann lange Gedanken gemacht, ob ich das auch machen will. Also einerseits aus datenschutzrechtlichen Gründen, also überhaupt datenschutztechnischen Gründen. Und ich will, dass diese Daten überhaupt erhoben werden. Und vertrauenswürdig ich dann die Akteure finde, die dann meine Daten haben. Und andererseits halt auch aus medizinischen Gesichtspunkten, also gerade wenn man so über Nocebo-Effekte nachdenkt oder so. Nocebo, das ist das Gegenteil von Blatzebo. Also dir wird gesagt, du hast eine höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit, krank zu werden und dann wirst du auch wahrscheinlich erkrankt. Diese Geschichte. Da habe ich mir Gedanken drüber gemacht und irgendwann, habe ich mir gedacht, ja, also ich habe mir das ausreichend Gedanken gemacht und ich will ein bisschen Spaß am Gerät haben und habe dann meine Speichelprobe dahingeschickt.
Und das funktioniert tatsächlich nur mit Speichelprobe und hast dann was zurückbekommen?
Zurückbekommen, bekommt man da erstmal eine E-Mail, so von wegen, wir haben jetzt deine Speichelprobe bekommen und dann dauert es irgendwie drei, vier Wochen und dann bekommt man noch eine Mail und dann sagen die einem so, jetzt haben wir das analysiert und jetzt kannst du dich hier einloggen und kannst mal so deine Daten entweder ganz hoch runterladen und hast dann irgendwie so ein 25 Megabyte Text-File, wo dann eine Million sogenannte SNPs drin sind, die du vergleichen kannst mit Software oder du kannst es dir eben auf der Webseite direkt schon aufbereitet angucken, was für Risiken und was für Phänotypen du so in dir trägst. Charakterzüge eher weniger, deswegen habe ich mich da auch gerade geregiert, aber du kannst halt so lesen, du hast wahrscheinlich braune Augen und du hast wahrscheinlich Blutgruppe A0 und solche Geschichten und du kannst halt auch gucken, wo kommen deine Vorfahren her, welche Haplogruppen hast du so und alles total spannend finde ich.
Aber du hast jetzt auch gerade mit den Krankheiten das erzählt, das stelle ich mir schon gruselig vor. Man sitzt dann irgendwie vorm Rechner und denkt so, okay, mache ich das jetzt auf oder nicht?
Ja, ja genau, also das ist in der Tat erstmal die Überlegung gewesen, will ich das überhaupt wissen, will ich überhaupt diese Analyse machen und dann natürlich nochmal in die Überlegung zu gucken, wie sieht es denn jetzt aus? Ist da wirklich etwas ganz schräg in meinem Genom oder ist das halbwegs okay? Aber das ist dann eine Entscheidung, die muss jeder für sich selber persönlich treffen. Das ist auch so eine Frage der eigenen Freiheit.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich würde jetzt nicht nachfragen, ob und was du da entdeckt hast, aber mich würde schon interessieren, ob du anderen Leuten empfehlen würdest, das auch zu machen, jetzt nachdem du es sozusagen getan hast.
Also ich würde auf jeden Fall nicht empfehlen, das jetzt einfach mal so hopp-a-li-hopp irgendwie mal schnell zu machen. Man sollte sich da gut informieren und am besten hat man auch so ein bisschen Vorwissen, gerade was medizinische Studien angeht und was Wahrscheinlichkeiten bedeuten. Und da steht irgendwie, da ist eine 1, 7-fache Chance, Dingsbums zu bekommen, was es dann konkret bedeutet und welche Statistik dahinter steht. Auf jeden Fall mit dem Thema erst mal beschäftigen und nicht irgendwie mal schnell, schnell kippen, weil es gerade billig ist.
Jetzt hast du ja sozusagen, also ganz am Anfang, bevor das Gespräch angefangen hat, gleich klargestellt, du findest dieses Instrument, was es hier beim Massen-Gent ist, was da verwendet wird, um Leute dazu zu pressen, das aufzumachen, findest du nicht gut. Du hast dich aber entschieden, das zu machen und läufst damit ja auch in Gefahr, dass diese Daten möglicherweise mal von dem Betreiber, wo du bist, irgendwo anders landen. Wie hast du da die Abwägung gemacht?
Die Abwägung ist natürlich, einerseits vertraue ich dieser Firma, das ist natürlich ein bisschen albern auch, weil die Firma kann von irgendjemand gekauft werden und dann sind die Daten da mit dabei. Das Risiko gibt es natürlich. Auf der anderen Seite sind es halt auch andere Daten erstmal. Also es sind nicht diese STRs, sondern es sind FNPs. Das sind natürlich potenziell noch reichere Daten, weil da wirklich nicht genommlich sekreziert wird, sondern gematcht wird auf festgelegte Punkte. Aber es ist eine Abwägung und wie gesagt, das muss jeder für sich selbst entscheiden. Ich persönlich glaube, dass ich, ich hinterlasse sowieso überall Spuren, die könnte man auch analysieren. Und dass diese Daten jetzt schon textuell irgendwo vorliegen, ja es ist ein zusätzliches Risiko, aber ich finde es jetzt nicht so super schlimm.
Das hat sozusagen für dich aufgewogen mit dem Interesse, was du an dem Thema einfach hast? Und du hast jetzt, das wollte ich nachfragen, einem von einem Subscription Service erzählt, das heißt du hast ein Abo und schickst irgendwie jeden Monat eine Speichelprobe hin, oder was bedeutet das?
Nee, nee, also jeden Monat, das wäre ein bisschen albern, weil so viel verändert sich ja in der DNA hoffentlich nicht. Ja, ja, aber was halt passiert ist, die Forschung kommt weit und korreliert Gene und Stellen im Genom mit neuen Erkenntnissen und neuen Merkmalen. Und das ist eben dieser Subscription Service, der dir dann sagt, wir haben jetzt hier eine neue Studie gefunden oder selbst gemacht. Und das zeigt uns das Folgendes. Also da kriegt man halt dann so ein Jahr lang Updates quasi, was die Wissenschaft Neues in deinem Genom gefunden hat.
Und weil du gerade dran bist, noch eine letzte Frage von mir, und dann hat Uta auch noch eine. Würdest du, wenn so ein Massengednis auf dich zukommt, da mitmachen oder würdest du dich auch dagegen wehren?
Nein, ich würde mich da wehren, bis auf die letzte Haut. Also es mag jetzt absurd klingen, aber da ist mir meine persönliche informationale Selbstbestimmung wichtig. Und dass ich das für mich persönlich mache, ist eine Sache. Und dass ich zu etwas gezwungen werden soll, auch wenn man nicht sagt, es ist freiwillig, obwohl es nicht freiwillig ist, dann ist das was anderes und dann werde ich auch niemandem genommen mehr geben.
Alles klar. Uta hatte noch eine Frage an dich.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur wissen, ob du uns verrätst, bei wem du das gemacht hast, bei welcher Firma.
Ja, also das ist 23andMe heißt die Firma. Das ist irgendwie eine kleine Firma, die auch Google investiert hat, insofern auch ganz böse eigentlich. Die machen für mich einen halbwegs seriösen Eindruck. Und das muss dann auch jeder für sich wissen, wen er da beauftragt und wo er das machen lässt.
Also ich kann dazu nur sagen, ich will dich da nicht brenzen. Und das ist natürlich immer die eigene Entscheidung. Aber gerade 23andMe ist tatsächlich auch dabei, sich auf dem Forschungsmarkt so ein bisschen zu platzieren. Und die haben so ein Programm angefangen, dass sie eben auch die Leute fragen, ob sie bereit wären, ihre Daten, also ihre Gen-Daten eben auch für Forschung bereitzustellen. Und das ist dann was, wo du nämlich schon anfängst, keine Kontrolle mehr darüber zu haben.
Naja, solange ich gefragt werde, ob ich will oder nicht, ist das ja okay. Also da würde ich auch mit dem Gedanken spielen, will ich da der Forschung meinen Genom zur Verfügung stellen. Das ist ja dann, passiert ja dann auch nicht mit irgendwie, das ist mein Name und das ist meine Adresse, sondern das ist passiert ja dann auch unter kontrollierten und anonymisierten Zuständen oder pseudonymisierten Zuständen zumindest. Und da muss man dann auch wieder für sich entscheiden. Aber ich denke, da habe ich soweit Vertrauen. Das kann man jetzt naiv finden oder nicht. Aber ich mir geht es damit mit der Entscheidung nach vor gut.
Haben die Anwesenden noch Fragen an den Herren?
Ich zuerst, haha. Und das beunruhigt dich nicht, dass das jetzt eine Firma ist, die diese Daten irgendwo abgelegt hat. Nehmen wir mal an, diese ganzen Web-Applikationen sind sicher, wo ich jetzt auch noch nicht das ungefähr glauben würde. Deswegen habe ich mich auch tatsächlich selber dagegen entschieden, das selber zu machen bei 23andMe. Aber es ist eine Firma in einer Juristikation, die jetzt ein bisschen weit weg ist. Und es wäre nicht das erste Mal, dass irgendeine Ermittlungsbehörde mit einem richterlichen Beschluss zu einer Firma kommt und sagt, gib mal Daten her.
Ja, das kann natürlich passieren.
Dann ist das ja auch, also so richtig freiwillig ist das dann ja für dich auch nicht mehr.
Nee, dann war ich halt dumm. Also das sind auch riesige Risiken gibt es da natürlich zuhauf. Und über die macht man sich auch Gedanken. Umgekehrt, das ist aber dann schon nochmal ein Unterschied, ob man jetzt da irgendwie falsch vertraut hat oder irgendwie unter falschen Annahmen was freiwillig gemacht hat oder ob man dazu gezwungen wird.
Ja stimmt, aber du hast denen zumindest damit die Kosten abgenommen. Das ist schon mal sehr großzügig von dir.
So kann man so sehen, ja.
So, jetzt haben wir, also irgendwie das, was der Martin da gemacht hat, scheint natürlich sehr interessant zu sein. Jetzt haben wir nämlich noch einen Anrufer, einen weiteren, der dazu sich äußern will, aber den ich gerade nicht dran nehmen kann, weil die Telefonanlage mal wieder spinnt. Na ja, Technik und so, liegt bestimmt daran, dass der Chaos Computer Club gerade hier ist. Ja, das kann ja jeder sagen. Martin, vielen Dank auf jeden Fall und viel Spaß mit deinem Genom. Bis denn, tschüss. So, interessant das mal zu hören von jemand, der das sozusagen von jemand anders hat machen lassen. Und Sil, die ja hier ist, hat das ja selbst versucht. Also nicht das, sondern diese andere Art von DNA-Profiling, über die wir die ganze Zeit sprechen, die ja sozusagen ein bisschen gröber ist. Erzähl mal, wie geht denn das? Kann man das tatsächlich zu Hause machen?
Das kann man tatsächlich zu Hause machen. Wir hatten das vorhin auf der Herfahrt schon kurz. Das Uta vermutete, man braucht da abenteuerliche Gerätschaften und ein Studium und dann noch drei Jahre Training in einem Bootcamp. Ist aber nicht so. Also die Gerätschaften, die man dafür braucht, kriegt man für einen, weiß ich nicht, ein Tausender, pessimistisch geschätzt sogar nur. Und wenn man das alles zusammen hat, dann kann man im Internet nachlesen, wie das geht. Und dann probiert man das mal aus und es funktioniert alles nicht. Und irgendwann funktioniert es dann mal. Und ich habe jetzt überhaupt gar keinen Hintergrund in Biologie. Also das kann man tatsächlich mit relativ wenig Hintergrundwissen auch selber ausprobieren. Und da ging es jetzt um STRs. Also ich habe mir einfach aus diesem, also es gibt ja bestimmte Loki, hatten wir ja vorhin festgestellt. Und dafür gibt es auch schon veröffentlichte Primer. Also diese kleinen Stückchen DNA, die man quasi als Angelhaken benutzt, um die Stücke, diese Marker da rauszufischen. Einfach aus dem Internet gesucht, welche man da benutzt, die mal synthetisieren und mir zuschicken lassen. Und das dann mal zu Hause probiert. Und das ging auch. Und dann musste ich mir noch irgendwie ein paar Freunde suchen, weil ich gerne als Vergleich... Ich brauchte halt was, wo ein Y-Chromosom drin ist. Kann ich nicht mitdienen. Also Freunde suchen, Freiwillige, Freiwillige, tatsächlich, ich hab sie. Das war wirklich mein Freiwillige. Ich hab sie nicht hinter der Tür gestanden. Nee, nee, nee, ganz lieb und nett gefragt. Und dann ging das auch. Und das war auch so eine Erwägung. Ich hatte ja kurz erwähnt, dass ich auch überlegt hatte, 23andMe das mal zu machen. Hab mich aber tatsächlich dagegen entschieden, weil mir das alles zu komisch war, dass so eine komische US-Firma meine Daten zu überantworten. Und die andere Überlegung war noch, es dauert wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so furchtbar lange, bis ich das auch selber kann. Dann mach ich es doch lieber selber zu Hause. Da weiß ich wenigstens, was ich hab.
Wie lange würde es noch dauern, bis du den großen Test auch zu Hause machen kannst?
Das kommt drauf an, wie viel ich verpeile, würde ich mal sagen.
Also gehen wir mal von dem unrealistischen Fall der Nullverpeilung aus.
Beim unrealistischen Fall der Nullverpeilung kommt es darauf an, wie viele Snips ich mir tatsächlich angucken will. Ich würde wahrscheinlich erst mal ein paar anfangen. Aber wenn ich mir ein paar rausgesucht habe, geht das wahrscheinlich innerhalb von ein paar Wochen. So mit Rücklauf, was Bestellungen angeht und Warten auf Lieferungen und solche Geschichten.
Aber dieses Zeug, was du da bestellst, das kann man sich einfach so ordern? Oder braucht man spezielle Kontakte, Bedarfsscheine oder Stempel?
Nö, das kann man sich einfach so ordern.
Okay, nicht schlecht. Jetzt wissen wir also, dass man das im Zahlverfahren auch bald zu Hause machen kann. Aber der eigentliche Teil, mit dem wir heute hier angefangen haben, ist ja, dass die offiziellen Behörden dieses DNA-Profiling machen, um damit Leute zu finden. Das heißt, das klingt in der Theorie erst mal so, Alter, wir haben ein DNA-Profil und dann wissen wir ganz genau, wenn wir das DNA-Profil nochmal finden, das sind dieselben Personen. Und das sind aber, haben wir ganz am Anfang gesehen, auch geklärt, eine statistische Wahrscheinlichkeit. Die sind relativ hoch, aber nun ja, da können auch Dinge schiefgehen. Und das sind natürlich immer die spannendsten Teile, die Anekdoten, wo das tatsächlich mal schiefgegangen ist. Wir haben jetzt zur Auswahl das Phantom von Heilbronn oder menschliche Chimären. Womit wollen wir anfangen?
Oder einige Zwillinge. Fangen wir mal ganz einfach mit den einigen Zwillingen an.
Die gibt es ja hier in Berlin.
Ich erzähle die Geschichte gerne, aber es ist eine meiner Lieblingsgeschichten. Das ist ganz kurz. Das kennt auch wahrscheinlich fast jeder. In Berlin gab es vor zwei Jahren, glaube ich, in KDW einen Juwelenraub. Und dann wurden DNA-Spuren am Tatort gefunden. Und es wurden auch relativ schnell zwei Brüder festgenommen, die dann eben zur DNA-Probe auch richterlich gezwungen wurden. Also per richterlicher Anordnung wurde eine DNA-Probe gemacht, ein Profil erstellt und es stellte sich eben heraus, dass beide Brüder, die nämlich eineinige Zwillinge waren, dass die DNA eben vollständig auch übereinstimmte mit der Spurenprobe. Da aber juristisch man nicht einem der beiden das eindeutig zuordnen konnte, sondern beide gleichzeitig sozusagen im Verdacht standen mussten sie beide freigelassen werden. Wir haben sich dann auch noch beim deutschen Rechtsstaat bedankt und sind vorhin abgedampft, wo die Juwelen geblieben sind, weiß auch niemand. Das ist halt ein Fall, der eben natürlich selten ist, aber da ist die Methode dann doch recht bisher recht hilflos.
Hatten die dann irgendwie ein Alibi oder sowas für die Zeit?
Brauchten sie ja nicht, sie haben auch nichts gesagt zu dem Fall. Sie haben einfach geschwiegen und haben die Technik arbeiten lassen für sich.
Aber wie haben sie denn sozusagen, also wenn es sonst keine Verdachtsmomente gab, wie sind die denn überhaupt auf diese beiden Typen gekommen?
Ne, das weiß ich nicht, es gab wahrscheinlich schon Verdachtsmomente. Aber die beiden haben eben geschwiegen einfach, die haben zum Tatergang nichts gesagt, die haben sich einfach nicht geäußert und haben die Technik für sich erarbeitet. Das haben wir wahrscheinlich vorher schon gewusst, woraus hinausläuft.
Alter Schwede!
Daran wird natürlich jetzt auch gearbeitet, also das ist eben auch eine der Forschungsfragen der Forensik, wie kann man eine Eige Zwillinge eindeutig mit einem DNA-Profil...
Na wir halten mal fest, eine Eige Zwillinge sind jetzt erstmal grundsätzlich verdächtig. Also ist doch sozusagen, aus dem, was wir heute schon gelernt haben, folgt das doch eigentlich direkt. Okay, dann möchte ich als nächstes gerne, finde ich nämlich das Spannendste, die menschliche Chimäre. Also Chimären sind, um mal euren Bildungshorizont ein bisschen zu erweitern, das sind Mischwesen aus der Fabelwelt. Also der greift zum Beispiel diese Mischung aus Löwe und Adler, ist zum Beispiel eine Chimäre. Was sind denn jetzt menschliche Chimären?
Wer will?
Ich?
Also menschliche Chimären, genetische Chimären, gibt es wohl auch in der Natur, ist aber echt selten, also dass sowas von sich aus entsteht. Es gibt Menschen, die in unterschiedlichen Körperzellen unterschiedliche Genome haben. Passiert aber tatsächlich relativ oft, wenn jemand eine Knochenmarkstransplantation hatte. Bei Blutkörperchen werden Knochenmark gebildet. Und das heißt, das Blut hat denn das genetische Profil vom Spender. Alle anderen Körperzellen haben das genetische Profil vom Menschen, also vom Empfangenden. Und das heißt, wenn man zwei Proben von diesen Menschen nimmt, Blutprobe und irgendwie Mund-Schleimhautabstrich, werden die sich unterscheiden. Wenn jemand dort Blut hinterlässt und dann in so einem Massen-Gentest ein Mundabstrich gemacht wird, wird man den nicht finden.
Dann kann gleichzeitig noch jemand anders damit belang?
Ja, das wäre ganz schön asozial, aber grundsätzlich ja. Also es wird wahrscheinlich auffallen, wenn zum Beispiel die verdächtigende Frau ist und der Spender ein Mann. Da wird der Labortechniker wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen stutzig werden. Aber sonst?
Also ich blute sozusagen in den Tatort, erwecke damit den Eindruck, da sei jemand gewesen, den könne man auch feststellen, aber bin dann jemand anders. Das ist ja sehr praktisch für gewisse Leute möglicherweise. Dann haben wir noch das Phantom von Halbron. Auch eine sehr schöne Geschichte. Dann ist jetzt quasi Susanne eigentlich dran, oder?
Das haben wahrscheinlich viele gehört. Viele haben das in den Medien mitbekommen. Das war wirklich mal so ein großes Scheitern der DNA-Suchaktion. Da ging es darum, dass grenzüberschreitende in mehreren Ländern Polizeibehörden ermittelt haben und nach einer Frau gesucht haben, weil sie Spuren bei Mordfällen, vielen Mordfällen gefunden haben, immer dasselbe Spurenprofil. Und deswegen miteinander verbunden haben, diese ganzen Mordfälle. Und dann gab es verschiedene Sonderkommissionen jahrelang gesucht nach dieser Frau, dieser Mörderin eben, bis sie eines Tages dann auch als Ermittlungsansatz hatten, zu überlegen, vielleicht gab es auch eine Kontamination. Das heißt, vielleicht kam dieses Profil, was sie da die ganze Zeit analysiert hatten, gar nicht von der Täterin oder dem Täter, sondern eben von jemand, die mit den Techniken zu tun hatte. In diesem Fall war das eine Verpackerin der Wattestäbchen, die alle da eingesetzt wurden, um Proben zu nehmen an den Tatorten. Das war dann sozusagen das Phantom-Volten. Heilbrauen in Wirklichkeit hatten diese ganzen verschiedenen Taten eben nichts miteinander zu tun und wurden nur so zusammengeführt.
Wenn ich richtig informiert war, war es doch auch so, dass diese Kontaminationen auch daher kamen, dass sie Wattestäbchen verwendet haben, die jetzt eigentlich nicht für diesen Zweck gedacht waren. Sie sind quasi einfach in die Drohung gegangen, haben Wattestäbchen gekauft und haben halt nicht spezielle DNA.
Sie hatten halt im Einkauf geguckt, die Sterilen sind ja viel billiger als die DNA-freien. Aber Steril reicht halt nicht.
Ganz DNA-frei kriegt man diese Dinger wohl auch nicht. Soweit ich gehört habe.
Aber wenn es schon DNA-frei gibt, muss man die nicht kaufen, wenn man DNA-Tests macht. Das ist total Quatsch.
Auf jeden Fall ist das ein typisches Beispiel dafür. Je feiner die Methoden werden, je geringere Spuren schon ausreichen, desto größer ist auch die Möglichkeit von Kontinuinationen.
Vorher hast du das, dass man die nicht ganz DNA-frei bekommt?
Habe ich irgendwo gelesen.
Eigentlich geht das schon. Wie macht man was DNA-frei? Behandeln mit Chemikalien. Das braucht man in Laboren auch relativ häufig, dass bestimmte Chemikalien und Substrate DNA-frei sein müssen.
Es gab in der BKA eine Stichprobe-Untersuchung. Die haben noch einige andere Fälle gefunden, wo die Spur-Spur-Treffer auf Kriminalbeamte hingewiesen haben. Polizisten oder Labortechniker. Relativ viele fand ich in dieser komischen. Das hat der Spiegel mal veröffentlicht.
Polizisten, eineilige Zwillinge und Massengentestverweigere.
Ihr seid alle, alle, alle verdächtig.
Jetzt wollen sie deswegen am liebsten die ganzen Labortechniker und Polizisten wiederum in Datenbanken erfassen. Das nennt sich dann Elimination Databanks, um sozusagen dann auszuschließen, dass wenn man diese Spuren findet, dass man die lieber gar nicht weiterverfolgt. Und da weigern sich aber dann in Deutschland zumindest die Polizisten.
Du meinst dieselben Leute, die sich auch weigern, irgendwie eine eindeutige Nummer auf dem Anzug zu tragen?
Genau, so was. Da fällt in plötzlich der gläserne Bürger ein, zumindest der gläserne Polizist.
Sehr, sehr. Aber das ist ja auch geil, wenn es dann so was gäbe, könnte man ein Polizist werden, könnte dann das perfekte Verbrechen. Weil man kann ja nicht am Tatort. Also ich meine, man ist ja dann in dieser Elimination-Datemark. Wäre vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht. So, jetzt wissen wir also, wie man DNA-Profile erstellt, wo die gespeichert werden und auch wie es schief gehen kann. Und was man warum dagegen macht, kennen wir gleich noch. Jetzt gibt es erst einmal das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Heute mal wieder, weil letzter Donnerstag im Oerre das Chaos Radio und zu Gast sind sie ihm zur Folge zum Beispiel jemand aus dem Chaos Computer Club. Das macht ja irgendwie Sinn. Die SIL nämlich. Hallo und guten Abend. Und vom Gen-Ethischen Netzwerk, Susanne Schultz und Uta Wagenmann. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal zum letzten Mal. Wir sind jetzt an einem Punkt der Sendung angekommen, wo es keinen Sinn macht euch nochmal genau zu erklären, was wir schon alles besprochen haben, weil das genauso lange dauern würde, wie die Sendung noch geht. Deswegen, falls ihr gerade einschaltet und euch für DNA-Profiling interessiert, also das, was die Behörden mit euch machen, wenn ihr so eine Speichelprobe abgeben müsst und wo sie das alles speichern und wie sie das machen und warum sie das dürfen und überhaupt empfehle ich euch den Podcast auf fritz.de oder chaosradio.de, der kurz nach der Sendung dann irgendwann immer erscheint. Also wir haben schon geklärt, dass doch ganz kurz gesagt, also wie es geht, wer das macht und wo das Ganze abgespeichert wird. Wir haben auch schon erklärt bekommen, wie das schiefgehen kann, also dass DNA-Profile jetzt irgendwie nicht der Weisheit letzter Schluss sind. Und was mich jetzt noch mal interessieren würde, und da hat Sil schon gemeint, das sei alles hochspekulativ, aber natürlich trotzdem spannend, wie man das Ganze hacken kann. Also im Chat meinen sie zum Beispiel, wenn es so eine Elimination-Datenbank gäbe, dann könnte man sehr da sein, DNA-Profil reintun, wäre fortfrei von aller Schuld. Aber dass diese Datenbank noch nicht gibt, geht das noch nicht, aber kann man das sonst irgendwie damit Unsinn anstellen?
Unsinn anstellen? Ja, Unsinn anstellen, dass es sogar akademisch belegt. Ich habe vor zwei Jahren meinen Aufsatz von ein paar israelischen Wissenschaftlern, die einfach nur mal dargelegt haben, was eigentlich allen Forensikern wahrscheinlich klar ist, nämlich dass solche DNA-Spuren an und für sich relativ leicht zu fabrizieren sind. Das sind ja einfach nur lange Stückchen von DNA, die eine bestimmte Länge haben müssen. Vorne und hinten das entsprechende Gegenstück zu der Primer-Sequenz dran. Und fertig ist die Probe. Das ist dann nur DNA, die kann man dann sicherlich irgendwo verteilen. Im Idealfall würde man...
Warte mal, nur zum Verständnis also sagen, ich besorge mir von irgendjemand den Code und kann daraus sozusagen dann wieder eine DNA-Sprohbaste nicht irgendwo hinterlege.
Ja, also kannst du zum Beispiel irgendwo, wenn mal wieder unser Innenminister bei einem Bankett ist, das Glas klauen, das hatten wir ja vorhin schon, dass man aus Fingerabdrücken auch im Zweifelsfall so DNA-Proben extrahieren kann, rausfinden, welches Profil das ist und dir dann so kleine Fläschchen mit Innenminister-DNA bestellen in den Küchenschrank.
Wir machen uns eine kleine Innenminister-DNA. Also ok, du hast ja vorhin schon erklärt, also irgendwie, wenn man das selber, dieses Profil erstellen will, das kostet ungefähr 1000, aber man muss sich das Zeug anlesen. Ist das mit genau denselben Hausmitteln dann auch machbar, dass man das fälschen kann?
Na, nee, das ist ein bisschen aufregender. Also da würde man es, wenn man es ganz einfach macht, synthetisieren lassen von so einem Dienstleister. Das ist dann nicht ganz billig, also man zahlt derzeit ungefähr für so 15 Basenpaare, so was wie 8 Euro. Ich schätze mal, man kommt für so einen kompletten, wir hatten gesagt, nicht mehr genetischer Fängeabdruck sagen, sondern ein DNA-Profil, ein komplettes DNA-Profil schätze ich mal so auf 700, 800 Euro.
Aber wenn das dann untersucht wird, können die dann feststellen, dass es eigentlich nur ein DNA-Profil ist?
Ja, das können sie auf jeden Fall feststellen. Also das erste Problem ist, dass DNA außerhalb einer Zelle nicht unbeschränkt stabil ist, also unter UV-Licht zerfällt es halt irgendwann. Man könnte jetzt, jetzt wird spekulativ, diese Stückchen DNA in irgendwelche E coli oder Hefe-Zellkulunien einbringen und dann diese Zellen in den Züchten aufraspeln, kleine Fläschchen füllen. Dann wäre das auch ein bisschen länger stabil, aber so wie es jetzt gemacht wird, wie die Technologie jetzt funktioniert, kann man das nicht feststellen. Das war Teil dieses Aufsatzes, den ich erwähnte, das vorgeschlagen wurde, noch zu gucken, ob die DNA an den richtigen Stellen methyliert ist. Das ist nämlich nicht, wenn sie synthetisch hergestellt ist, sondern nur, wenn sie tatsächlich aus einem menschlichen Körper kommt.
Das ist das Thema doch in der Tat, zumindest theoretisch und hoch spekulativ angreifbar. Weil du gerade auch wieder den Dienst erwähntest, wo man DNA synthetisieren kann, da tauchte die Frage gerade noch auf diese Firmen, wo man das hinschickt, um seine DNA analysieren zu lassen. Prüfen die nach, von wem die kommt? Also stellen die irgendwie sicher, das ist deine eigenes oder kannst du da einfach irgendwas hinschicken?
Und ich wüsste nicht, wie sie es feststellen wollen würden.
Du könntest ja wenigstens den Anschein erwecken. Also über Facebook kannst du eine Ausweiskopie schicken, dann glauben die, dass du leer bist, der du überhaupt bist zu sein. Also das wird also nicht gemacht, ich schicke deine Speichelprobe hin und die wird dann analysiert.
Ja, das hätten wir vorhin mal den Menschen fragen können, der hier so eine 23andMe-Geschichte gemacht hat, aber ich glaube, die machen das nicht.
Alright, so, jetzt kommen wir zu dem Punkt, wo die Leute vom genetischen Netzwerk, nämlich Uta und Susanne, die die ganze Zeit hier schon erklärt haben, was das geht und warum das geht und dass es davon große Datenbanken gibt. Warum sie morgen eine Symbol-Datenbank in einem großen Eimer Spucke versenken wollen. Was genau ist da los?
Ja, also wie wir ja schon anfangs erzählt haben, ist morgen der Stichtag, dass die ganzen europäischen DNA-Datenbanken, die ganzen europäischen Polizeien vernetzt sein sollen. Das heißt, sie sollen sich gegenseitig automatisch abgleichen können. Man soll gegenseitig da abfragen und die Polizeien können sich gegenseitig abfragen. Das ist morgens der offizielle Stichtag. Das ist dann zu Ende. Also, dass es komplett sein soll, die Vernetzung.
Wir haben am Anfang gesagt, dass ihr folgendes DNA-Profil in der Datenbank habt. Das soll dann mehr sein?
Nein, das soll jetzt einfach fertig sein. Alle Polizeien sollen da jetzt vernetzt sein. Das hat aber nicht geklappt, weil das zum Teil in manchen Ländern noch gar keine zentrale DNA-Datenbank gab oder gibt, weil noch technische Probleme da sind. Aber im Prinzip ist morgen der Stichtag offiziell. Prümen soll sozusagen dieser Prozesse abgeschlossen sein. Das soll alles funktionieren. Prümen ist der Vertrag, der war erst zwischen wenigen europäischen Ländern, eben aus deutscher Initiative heraus, und hat es in Prümen, in der Eifel, damals unterzeichnet worden. Und dann hat die EU das sozusagen komplett übernommen, diesen ersten mal freiwilligen Vertrag, also Vertrag zwischen verschiedenen Ländern. Und morgen haben wir den Stichtag einfach ausgewählt, auch wenn das sozusagen ja nur offiziell ist und noch nicht tatsächlich alles funktioniert, aber es wird in den nächsten Jahren funktionieren, um darauf hinzuweisen, dass eben diese DNA-Datenbanken international vernetzt werden und auch überhaupt in ganz vielen Ländern immer mehr DNA-Datenbanken aufgebaut werden und inzwischen auch mit den USA-Datenaustausch geplant ist, DNA-Datenaustausch um eben gegen diese Massen an Datenbanken, die sich in den letzten Jahren entwickeln und explodieren sozusagen in der Zukunft, um dagegen zu protestieren. Und da gehen wir deswegen vor die EU-Kommission morgen an der Pariser Platz, Ecke Wilhelmstraße, 12 Uhr. Seid ihr alle herzlich eingeladen. Heute machen wir eine kleine Kundgebung, in dem wir einen Datenträger, eine Festplatte und genau, wir wollen den Speichel benutzen, wir können darauf spucken, wir können damit machen, was wir wollen, aber wir geben ihn nicht an der Datenbank ab und wir machen keine Speichelproben.
Und dabei sein wird auch Willi Watte, das ist das Maskottchen unserer Kampagne. Willi Watte ist ein Wattestäbchen, das sich politisiert hat, das ist derzeit wirklich das politisch aktivste Wattestäbchen überhaupt, glaube ich, also weltweit würde ich mal behaupten. Willi Watte ist jetzt in den letzten Monaten viel unterwegs gewesen, hat sich wirklich, hat ja den offenen Brief, den wir an die Bundesjustizministerin geschrieben haben, der übrigens auch unterschrieben werden kann, der ist im Netz zu finden unter www.finger-weg-von-meiner-dna.de, da kann der unterschrieben werden und da werden eben verschiedene Forderungen gestellt, unter anderem Gesetzesrevisionen und eben unabhängige Prüfungen dieser ganzen Datenbank beim BKA und eben auch ein Ausstieg aus diesen Abkommen und aus dieser internationalen Vernetzung. Und genau das hat Willi Watte eben wirklich überall auf der ganzen, in der ganzen Stadt zumindest, also er war vorwiegend in Berlin unterwegs, hat da versucht, das unter die Leute zu bringen. Wir waren beim Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten hier in Berlin, der hat sich auch sehr interessiert vor unserer Forderung. Das wird auch auf der nächsten Konferenz der Landesdatenschutzer Thema sein, weil der Alexander Dix das eben da auch zur Sprache bringen will, der sieht da ganz ähnliche Probleme wie wir. Und ja, und Willi Watte hat unter anderem auch mit anderen Watte-Stäbchen zusammen, das waren fast, waren über 14.000, die er da mobilisieren konnte und mit unserer Hilfe dann auch haben wir das, die Nebenstelle des BKA hier in Berlin umzingelt. Das ist zwar nicht ohne Folgen geblieben, die Polizei stand dann auch gleich da und hat uns wegen Verstoßes gegen das Versammlungsgesetz gerügt und die Personalien vor allem aufgenommen, also wie immer Daten gesammelt ohne Ende. Das alles könnt ihr euch aber wirklich auch angucken auf www.fingerwegvonmeinerdna.de. Das ist eine sehr nette Seite, da kann man Filmchen gucken und sich ein bisschen in das Thema auch einlesen. Also, ist sehr vielseitig und wie gesagt morgen Willi am Pariser Platz um 12, da könnt ihr ihn reifhaftig kurz zusammen erleben.
Wer hat sich dazu bereit erklärt, dieses, wahrscheinlich so ein Ganzkörperkostüm zu tragen?
Oh, das machen wir alle gerne.
Willi ist eine, eine wirkliche, das ist eine echte, Okay, ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Aber tatsächlich noch mal zurück zu den Datenbanken. Also diese Vernetzung bedeutet genau was? Dass die vollautomatisch alle Daten in der Datenbank drin sind abgleichen oder dass es weiterhin nur sozusagen dieses Treffer austauschen ist?
Was genau? Also es werden, also zum Beispiel zwischen Niederland und Deutschland, als das geplant wurde, es werden alle Daten noch mal miteinander abgeglichen und da passiert dann auch schnell, also automatisch abgeglichen, ich glaube in regelmäßigen Abständen täglich, wöchentlich. Genau. Und dann mitgeguckt, dann gibt es auch öfters sozusagen Treffer, da ist auch ganz normal, dass dann falsche Treffer gibt, weil eben so viele Daten sind, dass immer wieder auch gleiche Profile vorkommen. Das zeigt eben auch schon wieder das Problem und das passiert dann dauernd und ansonsten gibt es diese No-Hit-Hit-Abfrage, die dann eben von den Polizeien untereinander gemacht werden kann. Das ist also eine Verbund-Datenbank, das ist keine zentralisierte EU-Datenbank, sondern eine Verbund-Datenbank der ganzen nationalen DNA-Datenbanken der Polizei.
Jeder hat seine, aber die sind alle online. Seid ihr jetzt generell dagegen, dass dieses Mittel-DNA-Profil zur Ermittlung eingesetzt wird oder seid ihr nur gegen die Datenbanken oder gibt es irgendwo eine Grenze, die ihr zieht?
Ja, wir haben darüber in unserer Forderung diskutiert, wir haben den offenen Brief auch so gestaltet, dass wir sagen, es gibt Mindest-Forderungen und es gibt sozusagen Maximal-Forderungen. Wir meinen, dass so eine zentrale Datenbank, dass die maximal fordern, dass die komplett gelöscht werden muss, weil wir meinen, dass solche Daten in zentral gespeichert in den Händen der Regierung problematische, überwachungsstaatliche Tendenzen fördern und man immer dann, wenn man erst mal so eine Datenbank hat, dann immer die auch ausgeweitet wird und die Tendenz immer ist, von Sicherheitspolitikern letztendlich die gesamte Bevölkerung speichern zu wollen. Weil es auch in manchen Ländern schon als Projekt gibt, also die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate zum Beispiel haben das jetzt schon als Projekt, dass sie die gesamte Bevölkerung DNA-Profile speichern wollen. Wir sagen aber auch, es gibt Mindestforderungen. Im Moment ist es halt so, dass noch nicht mehr die rechtlichen, also schon unheimlich laxen Grundlagen eingehalten werden. Also es gibt Datenschützer, die jetzt herausgefunden, also der Landesdatenschutzbeauftragte Baden-Württemberg hat mal eine Stichprobe gemacht. Mehr als Stichprobe werden da gar nicht kontrolliert. Beim LKA, also bei der Datenbank, das sind auch Verbunddatenbanken in Deutschland, LKA, was haben die gespeichert, hat eine Stichprobe gemacht und davon sind 42 Prozent nicht rechtens gespeichert gewesen und mussten gelöscht werden. Und das ist aber so, das findet nur alle paar Jahre statt. Die Datenschützer sind auch noch nicht besonders aktiv dazu, weil es wenig öffentlichen Druck bisher gibt. Das wollen wir auch ändern. Deswegen ist auch der Dix jetzt wirklich auch mal bereit, was zu machen, weil er merkt, da gibt es irgendwie Interesse. Und das ist also die Minimalforderung, dass zumindest die rechtlichen Bedingungen eingehalten werden. Auch, dass gelöscht wird nach zehn Jahren, dass überprüft wird, all das gibt es kaum unabhängige Kontrolle. Die nächste Forderung wäre eine Revision dieser, das, was jetzt erhebliche Straftaten ist. Das ist ja im Grunde diese Wiederholungstaten, dass eben Kleinkriminalität, jede Art von Vergehen schon jetzt inzwischen da auch gespeichert, also ein Anlass für eine Personenprofilerstellung sein kann. Da sagen wir auch, das muss auf jeden Fall zurückgeschraubt werden. Das ist sozusagen der nächste Schritt, mittelfristige Forderung, dass das ja total stark begrenzt wird, wann überhaupt eine DNA-Probe genommen werden darf.
Ich wollte mal kurz sagen, also einerseits geht es darum, dass diese Daten, wenn sie erhoben wurden, langfristig gespeichert werden in den Datenbanken. Andererseits geht es aber jetzt, also indem ich sozusagen zweite Baustelle quasi, es geht auch darum, wann dieses Mittel-DNA-Profilerstellen überhaupt benutzt wird. Warum seid ihr da dagegen, dass es überhaupt benutzt wird?
Unsere Kampagne ist erstmal wirklich gegen die Datenbanken, gegen die Speicherungen. Das ist unser Hauptproblem und dazu arbeiten wir jetzt und wollen das verhindern, wollen möglichst viele Daten gelöscht haben. Wir finden es was anderes, im ganz konkreten Ermittlungsfall, wenn das, was ich bei Mord oder Vergewaltigung, wenn das noch zusätzlich hinzugezogen wird, einfach nur praktisch die Identität nochmal zu klären, das haben wir uns jetzt so nicht zu geäußern, denke ich, das ist auch erstmal nicht das Problem. Wo wir uns allerdings auch skeptisch zu äußern, ist, dass es immer mehr Methoden gibt, die eben aus solchen Phantasy and Me-Projekten und aus verschiedenen riesigen Human-Genom-Forschungsprogrammen kommen, dass man das auch die Kriminalistik immer mehr versucht, bei einzelnen Spuren, die sie da hat, also nicht in der gesamten Datenbank, sondern bei einzelnen Spuren zu gucken, was kann man denn da alles rausfinden, über die Eigenschaften dieser Person. Und da sehen wir auch, dass es ein Problem ist, dass immer mehr versucht wird, nach Herkunft zu unterscheiden, was dann zum Beispiel wieder Migrationskontrolle relevant ist, wenn man sowas macht, zu gucken, aus welchen Regionen kommen Leute, dann will man die Augenfarbe, dann will man irgendwie die Größe, das ist bis jetzt noch alles sehr ungenau, aber wenn man übersetzt solche Erkenntnisse.
Aber das ist doch, ich muss kurz unterbrechen, bei dem was sie beschrieben hat, ist, dass spielt es noch gar keine Rolle, also diese STRs, was sie erklärt hat, da kann man das ja gar nicht draus ablesen.
Das wird bei den Spuren eben zum Teil, jetzt eben ist das eine Grauzone, das ist rechtlich eigentlich nicht erlaubt, also es dürfen keine anderen Merkmale rausgelesen werden.
Okay, das sind direkt Verboten, ist es überall in Europa so oder ist es nur in...
Also in Deutschland ist es so, ich wollte nur sagen, dass es eben durchaus aber Fälle gibt, wo dann in richterlicher Anordnung dieses Verbot doch irgendwie umgeht, weil gegründet mit Ermittlungsnotwendigkeit, weil es irgendwie keinen anderen Anhaltspunkt gibt und dann wird eben durchaus mal geguckt, wie alt ist die Person vielleicht gewesen oder wie ist die Herkunft, obwohl man eben die Tests, die man da an, also das sind ja dann eher eben Snips oder genetische Tests, wenn man die macht, die sind viel zu ungenau, also im Grunde kann man daraus nicht viel lesen und gerade das mit der Herkunft ist extrem, extrem zweifelhaft, ja, also Herkunft aus der DNA ablesen zu wollen, da gibt's viel zu, aber wir wollen es ja jetzt nicht ausweiten. Das bringt vielleicht noch mal kurz das Problem auf den Punkt, dass DNA-Proben deren Besonderheit eben auch ist, dass es biologisches Material ist, das heißt, es ist unendlich weiter zu spinnen, was da noch alles rausgelesen werden könnte, irgendwann mal, wenn es irgendwann mal als notwendig angesehen wird.
Das heißt, so die Begehrlichkeiten der Kriminalistik und verschiedene Zukunftsszenarien kann man sich vorstellen, auch wenn das jetzt noch nicht so funktioniert, wie sie sich das wünschen würden.
Das heißt, selbst wenn das sozusagen ganz sicher verschiedene Merkmale auszulesen wären, würde dir das als Ermittlungsmittel trotzdem nicht gut heißen?
Ja, weil dann kommt es dann als nächstes zur Speicherung, dann will man schon die Eigenschaften von Personen speichern, das sind ja immer so Schritte. Also da wären wir dagegen, dass man überhaupt mit solchen zweifelhaften Methoden arbeitet.
Okay, das finde ich zumindest eine spannende Sache, die ich wahrscheinlich diskussionswürdig finden könnte, wenn jetzt nicht die Sendung gleich vom Ende wäre. Wir haben jetzt noch einmal eine ganz kurze Frage von Gabriel. Hallo, guten Abend, mach's ganz schnell.
Hi, ich habe noch eine Frage zu der gefälschten DNA-Spur. Ihr habt gesagt, die würde man dann irgendwie synthetisieren lassen, die DNA. Wenn ich schon die DNA-Spur habe vom Innenminister, dann kann ich die doch einfach per PCR amplifizieren und dann großflächig verteilen, oder?
Okay, das ist ein schön viel Fachsprechen. Gabi, ich tue dich mal schon wieder raus, damit du sozusagen nicht aus dem Ruder laufst, weil wir nicht mehr viel Zeit haben. Aber die Frage war sozusagen, wenn man DNA hat, dann kann man die dann nicht einfach amplifizieren, also verstärkt kann man DNA verstärken?
Ja, also amplifizieren, das ist eigentlich das, was PCR tut. Da hat er schon recht. Da kann man noch einfach replizieren. Das ist ja eigentlich nur ein Replikator, die PCR-Maschine mit den Enzymen drin. Was ich eigentlich an dieser synthetisierten DNA spannend fand, war, dass man tatsächlich den Schritt gehen kann von einem digitalen Infobit, wenn jetzt auf Wikileaks irgendwann mal die Code des Datenbanks auftaucht, dass es dann relativ einfach ist, da die auszudrucken.
Wenn ich schon die DNA von jemanden habe, dann würde ich sie sozusagen anwachsen lassen, also vermehren? Okay, wenn ich nur den Code habe aus dieser Datenbank, dann kann ich sie aber immerhin synthetisch basteln? Gut, dann haben wir Gabriels Frage auch noch beantwortet. Wie seht ihr denn jetzt realistisch eingeschätzt die Zukunft dieses Unternehmens, dass ihr da einen Start gebracht habt? Malte ihr euch da irgendwas aus?
Naja, im Moment kann man sich eigentlich nur unangenehme Dinge ausmalen, wenn man sich das anguckt, wie die Vernetzung ist europaweit und so weiter. Wir können da sicherlich nur begrenzt gegen Anstinken, aber wir versuchen es weiter und hoffen auch sehr, dass wir da weiter vorankommen. Also man kann da nur kleine Schritte gehen, weil das ist eben leider sehr weit verbreitet, die Annahme, dass diese Datenbanken das Verbrechen aufklären und sonst nichts. Und das tun sie eben leider nur zu einem ganz gering fühlten Teil, wenn überhaupt.
Jetzt ist morgen dieser Aktionstag mit dem großen Spuckeeimer, den ich immer noch ein bisschen eklig finde. Aber gut, für die politische Aktivismus kann man das mal machen. Was ist denn danach der Plan? Also ich meine, die werden ja morgen nicht vor eurem Spuckeeimer umfallen und dann sagen, oh nein, wir werden deine Datenbanken löschen. Okay, mal gucken, aber nur potenziell abgenommen, das passiert nicht. Was passiert dann?
Also wir sammeln weiter ganz eifrig für den offenen Brief auch Unterschriften. Also nochmal www.fingerwegvonmeinerdna.de könnt ihr den mit unterschreiben und werden auch weiter insistieren, dass Frau Leuthäuser-Schnarrenberger sich da irgendwie zu äußert. Sie hat bisher den irgendwie zwar entgegengenommen, aber in ihrer Behörde ist er inzwischen irgendwie anscheinend verloren, der Brief. Und sie hat sich noch nicht justiziert. Also niemand weiß etwas davon, obwohl wir mehrmals den hingeschickt haben und mehrmals nachgefragt haben. Ist ihr anscheinend irgendwie unangenehm, wo sie ja schon mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu tun hat. Und wir wollen auch einfach noch mal klar machen, dass es eben biologische Vorratsdatenspeicherung und genauso problematisch wie die andere Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist. Wir freuen uns auch sehr, dass der Chaos Computer Club zum Beispiel das mit unterzeichnet hat und wir auch deswegen ja in Kontakt jetzt hier miteinander gekommen sind. Ja und wollen einfach weiter Kampagne, Informationen, Diskussionen fördern.
Also ihr habt diesen offenen Brief von Leuten und Institutionen unterschreiben lassen, habt den dort abgegeben oder wie macht das mit so einem offenen Brief? Schickt man den hin oder was?
Ja genau, das haben wir vorher eben auch versucht rauszufinden, haben angerufen, wurden dann eben auch natürlich und wunderbar.
Werte gehen Sie Dienststelle 33A und holen Sie das Kodefond?
Nee, also wir haben dann richtig mehrfach eben mit denen rumtelefoniert, mit verschiedenen Sachbearbeitern am Ministerbüro und hatten dann eigentlich auch den Termin und dann war auch klar, dass wir den da abgeben werden und da mussten wir dann allerdings nicht rein, weil die Polizei, die da war, die wollte nicht, dass wir in das Ministerium reingehen, die hatten Angst vor Willi Watte, der war da schon dabei, wahrscheinlich auch einfach, weil er so groß und umfangreich aussah, könnten ja auch Waffen drunter geschmuggelt werden, keine Ahnung, was sie gedacht haben. Wie auch immer, wir haben den Brief abgegeben, wir haben ihn vorher auch ein paar Mal per E-Mail dahingeschickt, damit die schon wissen, worum es geht und haben dazu noch eine schöne Kunstaktion gemacht. Also Willi hat da eben seine Wattestäbchen mitgebracht und wir haben dann da nochmal den Slogan unserer Kampagne DNA-Sammelwut stoppen, vor das Bundesjustizministerium geschrieben. Also die Wattestäbchen haben diesen Slogan geformt, haben eben gezeigt, dass sie sehr viel schönere Dinge tun können als Speichelsammeln. Und ja, dann haben wir den Brief da abgegeben bei einer Dame, die uns da empfangen hat. Das haben wir auch alles filmisch festgehalten. Und jetzt haben wir uns mal erkundigt, wie es so aussieht, weil drei Monate vergangen sind, seit wir den abgegeben haben und da hieß es dann eben, er sei irgendwie verloren gegangen. Sie wüssten gar nichts davon und das ist ein bisschen, tut mir leid, also ich glaube es nicht so ganz, dass er verloren gegangen ist. Ich nehme an, das passt gerade nicht ins Begriff.
Hey, offizielle Behörden können total super mit Daten umgehen.
Ja, aber wir bleiben da am Ball und ich denke wir werden auch noch genug politischen Druck entfalten, dass wir da endlich mal eine Antwort kriegen, weil die Frau muss sich dazu irgendwie äußern. Sie ist selber ja eigentlich sehr kritisch gegenüber dieser ganzen Vorratsdatenspeicherung Geschichte.
Aber das ist doch was ganz anderes jetzt. Ja, und wir machen auch weitere Informationskampagnen, dass Leute, die unter Umständen damit konfrontiert sind, dass sie mal ihre Streichelprobe abgeben sollen, dass sie wissen, dass sie eine richterliche Anordnung brauchen, dass sie sich verweigern können. Das ist auch immer ganz wichtig, immer wieder zu sagen. Wir haben auch so mit Willi Watte viele Leute getroffen, auf der Straße, die gesagt haben, gerade Jugendliche, mir ist das schon mal passiert, ich sollte das schon mal machen, und es wurde mir angedroht. Und es ist auch gut, dass die Leute das wissen, in Schulen und so weiter, das verbreiten.
Dann jetzt einmal noch die Webseite.
Genau, die Webseite www.fingerwegvonmeinerDNA.de Und ihr könnt auch, wenn ihr eine Geschichte zu erzählen habt, die euch passiert ist im Zusammenhang mit DNA-Speicherung, euch gerne auch ans Genetische Netzwerk selbst wenden. Das ist auch unter www.gen-ethisches-mit-th-netzwerk.de zu erreichen. Findet sich auf der Webseite fingerwegvonmeinerDNA.de Und da ist es ganz einfach uns zu kontaktieren. Und dann könnt ihr, wenn ihr eine Geschichte loswerden wollt, wir sammeln nämlich auch gerade Geschichten, die Leuten passiert sind im Zusammenhang mit DNA-Speicherung.
Uta Wagenmann und Susanne Schultz vom Gen-Ethischen Netzwerk. Oh Gott, beim letzten Mal verschwinden. Toll!
Das ist ein 80er-Jahrenname.
Okay, Chaos Radio ist ja eh gleich vorbei. Sill vom Chaos Computer Club auch hier gewesen. Was wird dein nächstes Projekt? Wessen DNA wirst du fälschen?
Würde ich niemals tun, es war das hochspekulative und rein empathetisch.
Dann vielen Dank euch allen drei. Und ihr könntet heute ganz ausführlich lernen, wie man das mit dem DNA-Profiling macht und wo und überhaupt. Morgen gibt es, wie gesagt, Spucke einmal vor der EU-Kommission in Berlin. Viel Spaß dabei.
12 Uhr.
Mir bleibt nur noch eins zu sagen. Lasst doch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Back-ups.